[Music]
test test.
Is that coming through on there?
>> Well, but it's clear.
Thank you.
Good evening everyone.
I'll now call to order this meeting of
committees of Lancaster City Council for
October 6, 2025.
Mr. Harris, would you please begin with
the roll call of members?
>> Yes, Madam President. Mr. Madden
>> here.
>> Mr. Roya
>> Mr. Glee
>> here. Miss Craig, Miss Diaz
>> here,
>> Mr. Hirs
>> and President B
>> here. Council Craig is excused this
evening. A few reminders and
announcements at the top of the meeting.
uh first ask that you please silence
your phones and devices if you haven't
done so already. This meeting and its
participants are being recorded. Um
thank you for bearing with us as we work
through some new uh audio uh challenges
with a new system. So there were there
will be some growing pains and thank you
for adapting with us. One of those is
that we are taking this committee
meeting from the deas um just because
we're still working on the wireless
microphones. Uh so that's why we're up
here this evening and not at our table.
Uh tonight again we have meetings of
committees of council. There's no
general public comment period during
these meetings. However, committee
chairs will call for comments uh from
the public for legislative items. That's
bills and resolutions. Uh comments are
limited to 3 minutes per speaker and you
must begin with your name and your block
of residence for our meeting record. Uh
to keep time during those comments, I
will use my light. It will be green when
the speaker begins. It will blink yellow
when there is a minute remaining and
then blink red when 3 minutes has been
exhausted.
Councilors, we'll move to the approval
of our September 2nd, 2025 committee
meeting minutes.
>> Motion to approve.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second.
Councilors, any comments on the minutes?
>> Hearing none. Mr. Harris.
>> Mr. Man.
>> I.
>> Mr. Royer.
>> Mr. Gleas.
>> I. Miss Diaz.
>> Hi,
>> Mr. Hirs.
>> I and President Beke.
>> I
That will take us to the personnel
committee meeting. Turning it over to
councelor Kix.
>> Thank you, Madame President. The
personal committee has four items on the
agenda for tonight. The first item is
the nomination of Theodor Griffitz for
appointment to the planning commission.
Uh the Mr. Griffitz was expected to
attend the meeting tonight, but uh
unfortunately for unforcing
circumstances, he cannot attend the
meeting tonight in order to tell us his
thoughts about his nomination.
So we expect him to attend the next
meeting on October 14th.
And so we move to the second item which
is the nomination of Heidi Sherk for
reappoint to the planning commission.
Miss Sherik currently serves on the
board for um but her term has expired.
So she's willing to be reappointed to
continue to serve on the board. With
that, I'll open up for comments or
questions for from the committee and
members of council.
Hearing none, any questions or comments
from the public?
So, thank you. So, we I'll make a motion
to move this nomination to our next
console meeting on October 14th.
>> Second.
>> All in favors? I
>> The next item is the nomination of Heidi
Sherk. No, no, the nomination of Ebe
Guerrero Lopez for reappointment to the
Lancaster Industrial Development
Authority.
And um
Miss Gera Lopez current term has expired
on the board and uh she's willing to be
reappointed.
And I'll open up for questions and
comments from members of the committee
and from council
from the public.
I'll make a motion to move this
nomination to Ironx Council meeting on
October 14th.
>> Second.
>> All in favors?
>> I. And the last item is the nomination
of Darcy Pollak
for reappointment to the Lancaster
County Convention Center Authority.
And
Mr. Pollock has been serving on the
board for quite some time and uh his
term has expired and he has expressed
his interest in uh being reappointed.
I'll open up for questions or comments
from members of the committee and from
council
from the public.
I'll make a motion to move this
nomination to our full council meeting
on October 14th. Second.
>> All in favors?
>> I I
>> So that concludes the person on the
committee. Madame President,
>> chair colleagues, uh I don't believe we
made a motion on Theodore Griffith's
nomination and I feel that we should uh
motion to move uh his nomination to our
October 14th meeting.
>> Okay. So I'll make a motion to move this
nomination to the next council meeting
on October 14th. Then
>> second.
>> All in favors? I
>> I.
>> So that concludes the personal
committee. Madam President,
>> thank you very much councelor Kag. Uh we
will look forward to seeing Mr.
Griffith. We have met him uh previously
during our ethics commission process.
We'll look forward to seeing him seeing
him in person at the next meeting. Uh
next we will move to the finance
committee. Councelor Royo. Thank you,
Council President. We have two items on
the agenda for this evening's finance
committee. Uh, administration bill
number 11 and administration bill number
12. I would invite Director Campbell who
will be giving a uh budget overview
presentation on the 2026 budget. Good
evening, Director Campbell.
Sometimes it just takes like a second.
Cool. Is that we got We'll go with that.
Oh, is are they both uh plugged in at
the same time? And is that okay?
Again, we're still learning a brand new
system.
>> Hi
While they're um working on that, maybe
I can just give the overview. Oh, there
we go. All right.
>> Great.
>> Um so, we will be talking about both of
these bills together. They they coincide
um with each other um both the budget
and the the real estate tax rates. Um
so, first of all, thank you all for
taking time to review the 2026 proposed
budget this evening. Um, I'm remembering
that when we were that at this time last
year, we were presenting you with two
different budgets. Um, I'm grateful we
don't have to produce two budgets this
year. This has definitely made the com
the budget process less complicated. Um,
though, as many of you who who have
created budgets know, there's still a
lot of work involved. So given that
before I dive into the budget itself, I
just wanted to um give a big thank you
to our accounting team who spent a lot
of hours on this and actually are
currently upstairs working on on um
ensuring that the budget booklet is is
working right. Um so it's definitely a
collective effort and we can't do this
with just one person or even just one
team though. So so just a big thanks to
all involved.
Um so tonight begins the the public
input portion of the 2026 budget
process. Um, we will have a draft of the
budget posted on the website tomorrow
morning and it will be available on
Engage Lancaster as well to make
comments on. I want to emphasize again
that this is a draft so nothing is set
in stone. There's a number of
opportunities for everyone to interact
with this budget before it is adopted.
Um, I have a schedule included at the
end of my presentation that we will go
over to talk about all of the dates and
options.
Um so let's jump in. Uh tonight um as we
have had as we've done traditionally I'm
going to give a very highlevel overview
of the budget. The budget hearings
coming up later this month and in
November we'll provide many more details
um from the departments and the various
funds on both the expenses and the
revenue in the budget.
The biggest noteworthy subject um the
mayor talked about this in her address.
Uh we are not proposing any increases in
taxes or fees for city residents this
year. This means no real estate or
earned income tax fee tax increase and
no increases in utility fees for inside
city customers. We did submit a water
rate case uh water rate increase case to
the PUC last week. Um so we do
anticipate an increase in water rates
for customers outside of the city um at
some point in 2026.
It's very unlikely that we will receive
approval for the full increase that we
requested. The PUC um doesn't typically
do that. Um so we do not know yet what
this increase will be nor do we know
when it will take place. The PUC um has
to process it first.
Um so a few other highlights uh for the
general fund. Um ARPA funding has now
ended. This means a reduction in income
from 2025 of 2.4 4 million.
Um earned income tax is coming in almost
exactly as we projected with the
increased rates this year. Um we're
anticipating that this will continue to
grow with the natural increases in
incomes. We continue to hear that
Lancaster County and city incomes are
continuing to increase and so we will
keep watching that based on national
trends as well.
Um this next point feels like a broken
record. Um but as is the case every
year, medical costs are rising as well
as pensions. Um the vast majority of our
salaries are set by collective
bargaining agreements and so those push
costs up as well.
Um there are 10 and a half positions
that are included in this year's general
fund budget um that were vacant
previously or are new. Um the mayor
noted the return of the chief of staff
position in her address on September
23rd. Um other positions are either
revenue neut neutral related to
permitting um and building code
functions or long overdue especially
those in HR and we will be discussing
each of those as we move through the
budget the department overviews at the
budget hearings on October 21st and
November 18th and then the enterprise
funds. So, um the water, sewer, storm
water, and the solid waste and recycling
fund. Those four uh will be discussed in
much greater detail on November 18th. Um
so, I will not get into those this
evening. Um other than my mention
earlier that we're not planning to
increase fees, uh within the city.
Okay. So, this slide shows um the total
of the operating expenses for all of the
city funds. So this includes both the
general fund um which is general
operations of the city and the four
enterprise funds that I just mentioned
the water fund sewer fund solid waste
and recycling and the storm water
management fund. This total is umund
159.6 million so about 160 million for
all funds combined. Um this is only
about a 1% total increase from last
year. um you can see that about 52%
of the total budget is the general fund.
And so because the general fund is such
a large portion of that budget, um I'm
going to spend the rest of the
presentation focused on that. And again,
as I just mentioned, the enterprise
funds will be addressed in more detail
on on November 18th.
So for the general fund, this graph
shows the breakdown of our revenue in
the regular budget or in the budget. We
don't have to worry about regular or
home rule budget anymore. Um the largest
portion of the funds come from property
taxes. Um but that's still just 42% of
the budget. So it's less than half of
the full budget. Um so the other sources
of revenue include earned income, which
is about 21% of the revenue. I will have
a slide on that a little bit later. um
real estate transfer tax and local
services tax. These taxes combined um
are not um a lot of revenue. It's only
about 4% of the total. Um and I'll share
a little bit more details on the real
estate transfer tax in a minute as well.
Um other revenue categories, uh the city
charges fees for some of the services um
as well as fines and those do bring in
revenue for the city. Um, between all of
the fees and and uh for services and
fines, this totals about 17% of our
regular budget revenue. And these
services include things like building
permits, plumbing licenses, zoning
permits, health licenses, right-of-way
permit fees, parking violations, and
public safety related activities.
Um, the other revenue category on here,
um, which is the third one on the list,
um, that's about 11% of the regular
budget. Um, this includes a a multitude
of revenue sources, including payments
from the enterprise funds for services
that the general fund provides. Um, and
also grant funds that have been awarded
to help with specific projects.
Um, and finally, as the mayor mentioned
in her speech on September 23rd, we are
using cash reserves of 1 million, uh,
which is about 1% of the budget. Um this
will still keep us at approximately 20%
in our cash reserve fund which is in
line with our proposed cash reserve
policy that is currently being
considered um within the home rule
administrative code.
And this um additionally this use of
reserve funds helps us to smooth the
ARPA cliff.
All right. So, just briefly, um, before
we look at expenses, um, well, before we
look at expenses, because we're not
going to spend a lot of time on revenue
during the budget hearings that are
coming up later, I did want to spend a
couple minutes on a couple of the
revenue categories.
Um, so we aren't proposing real estate
uh, increasing real estate taxes this
year, but I still uh, like to show this
chart each year. Um, this is the total
assessed value of real estate within the
city. And this um helps helps us to
determine the millage rate um of the
real estate tax. So this chart you can
see shows that there's very little
change in property assessments in the
city from year to year except in two
thou 2018 when the county implemented a
reassessment. Since that time the city's
overall tax base has grown only 3%. And
you can see that about a third of the
property um is taxexempt and cannot be
cannot be taxed.
So, we don't really see this number move
a whole lot. Um, I will say too that the
county is planning a tax reassessment in
2027. Um, this is the first one since
2018. Um, however, with those
reassessments, uh, we do need to lower
the tax millage rate to be revenue
neutral. Um, so we're not projecting any
significant increases in real estate tax
revenue over the next years.
All right. Um the real estate transfer
tax. Um this is the tax uh that happens
when a property is sold. So the city
splits this tax with the school
district. Um and this along with the
earned income tax often is a pretty good
indicator of a of whether or not the
economy is healthy. Um so the real
estate tax tends to increase ever so
slightly or stay the same in a healthy
real estate market. And you can say see
that playing out generally. There's a
few years in here with some anomalies
that you can see. So, I'll just mention
those. Um, in 2018, um, that's getting
towards the beginning of this chart.
Now, uh, Park City was actually sold.
So, that contributed to almost half the
taxes in this category for that year.
Um, 21 and 22, as we all know, were
periods of low mortgage interest rates
and a high push for property sales and
transfers. That was at a national level.
So, we saw that playing out here, too.
And then this year 2025 um we did see a
jump because of the real estate selling
for the data center um which pushed us
over what we had budgeted um but we
accounted for that anomaly in the budget
for 2026. We're not anticipating that
again and so we've kept the budget um
the same as 2025.
All right, on to earned income tax. Um
so as you know we increased the rate for
our earned income tax last year. We
spent quite a bit of time reviewing uh
the impacts of this on the 2025 budget
last year. Um based on the research and
the advice that we received, we included
uh what I'll describe as a lag for when
the increase would actually start. Um so
though the increase actually started
January 1st, we didn't assume in the
budget that we would actually see the
increase fully take effect until after
the first quarter of the year.
And as we analyze the as we have
analyzed the income through the end of
August this year, our budget appears to
be on on track for the actual income we
are receiving. So that appears to be um
a good projection for the year. So in
addition to the to the tax increase from
last year, we continue to see a slight
rise in income levels um which
contributes to a natural increase in
earned income tax income for the city.
Um, so over the past 10 years that has
averaged about 5% give or take and we're
continuing to see that trend. We're
we're watching the economy pretty
closely, but we think this will continue
into 2026.
So if you look at this graph closely, if
you like to um crunch numbers, you will
see that 2026 jumps more than 5% from
2025. And this is because we are
including a full year of the of
receiving the earned income tax at the
current level. now as well as the
natural income increase projections.
So, just wanted to to say that all to
make it clear that we're not projecting
an increase in the tax rates. We're
simply projecting that that income
increase um because of those factors.
All right. So, now we're going to look a
little bit at expenses. Um we have a a
couple of different graphs to show the
expenses for the general fund tonight.
And I wanted just to just start with
this one. Um we included this one for
the first time last year and I think it
gives a pretty good idea of the
breakdowns. Um so as you look at the
breakdowns of the general fund expenses,
uh our biggest expense categories are in
public safety. Uh this is this is always
the case. Um it's a total of about 54%
of our budget that goes to fire and
police. These are shown on the bottom
bar in red for police and and the dark
gray for fire. And last year, um, if you
remember the many discussions about
earned income tax in our home rule
conversations, we showed you that
property tax and earning income and
earned income tax, so our two highest,
um, income or revenue bases, um, only
covered the police and fire expenses for
the city while all of those services
required coverage from elsewhere. Um,
this chart shows that this is starting
to change for the first time thanks to
the earned income tax increase. So
property tax and earned income tax
because of this increase now make up
about 63% of the revenue budget. And
while this doesn't nearly cover all of
our services, it's a huge help as we
have reached that cliff for ARPA in 2025
that I was talking about and are needing
to increase support for some of the
other services without ARPA funding.
Uh and then this is just a a different
version of looking at the expenses um
for the general fund. Um after public
safety, the next largest category of
general expenses is the category that we
are now describing as supporting
expenses. Um this holds pension, medical
and debt expenses. So it's about 15% of
the total budget. Um this category also
includes just a very small amount of
funding for organizations like the
library, Lancaster wreck and um LEMs. Um
but that amounts to about less than 5%
of the total expenses for this category.
So of that 15%.
And then the other categories you can
see here um of the budget include the
remaining departments. Um, so CPAD, the
community planning and economic
development is at 7%, administrative
services is at 10%, public works is at
12%, and neighborhood engagement comes
in just just under 2% of the full
budget. The other two very tiny portions
totaling just over 1% of the budget
together um include the mayor and
solicitor's office and the elected work.
So, city council um city clerk and the
controller expenses.
This is another slide that we created
last year and I thought it might be be
helpful to see again. Um this shows the
difference in costs in in our four
categories of expenses in the general
fund. So the largest increase in cost
this year is in salaries. Um this is due
to adding positions that I mentioned in
the opening slide as well as finally
budgeting for a fully staffed uh police
bureau. We haven't done this for a
number of years, but thanks to some good
recruiting efforts this year, we're
feeling confident that we're going to be
close to fully staffed next year.
The next three slides I will move
through fairly quickly, but they show a
bit more detail about um the supporting
services. So, medical, pension, and
debt. These are, as I've been saying,
very large drivers of cost increases for
us. Um so, I just wanted to show these
briefly.
This is the medical expenses for the
city. Um, this is showing all funds. So,
it does include uh enterprise funds in
this budget as well. Year-over-year
medical costs have increased um an
average of 4.5% since 2016.
Saw some bigger jumps in 2021 and 2022
after COVID, but then some leveling out
in 2023, jumped again in 2024, and some
slighter lower increases in 25 and 26.
We are self-insured. Um, so these
numbers are results of much analysis,
but they are also still projections. We
watch these numbers pretty closely to
ensure that they're staying in line with
what we have projected. And
additionally, I will say the fact that
we're self-insured has helped to keep
these costs um down. They're not rising
as much as other organizations are
seeing. Um however, we are still
embarking on a pretty big project
reviewing these costs in 2026. Um which
we're hopeful will have positive results
on costs in 2027 and beyond while still
ensuring that we're pro providing a uh
top level of healthcare benefits to our
employees. So I will be talking more
about that on October 21st in my um
admin services presentation as well.
This slide shows the comparison of the
pension cost obligations for the city
versus the state pension aid that we
receive. So, as you can see, there's a
steady increase for the three combined
pensions, the police, fire, and
non-uniformed, the NU up there. Those
are the red, uh, black, and gray or
blue. I'm not sure what that that color
is. Um, and then the state pension aid
is the yellow bar. Um, so you can see
that that has increased at a much lower
rate. Our obligations have risen by 4.8
million in the last 10 years, while
state aid has only increased by 1.9
million during the same period.
Um, I don't think I showed this slide
last year, so I wanted to pull this out
again. Um, this is the general fund debt
service. Um, and as you can see, debt
did jump in 2024 because of the 2022
bond payments. Um some of the larger
projects in that bond were the creation
of the parks master plan. Um the police
department had some window replacements
and other renovations
um that were partially covered by a
grant, but we needed some capital
funding as well. And then some of the
costs of of the welcome center
renovations that weren't funded by the
grants we needed as well. It also
included much of the bike lane work
that's been completed throughout the
city. Um again in conjunction with some
grants for that work.
Um, I did want to note just one thing
that's not on this slide. Um, that's
relevant to the slide. Um, in the next
slide, you'll see an increase in 2027
for debt service. As I show these
10-year projections, um, this jump
accounts for the 2025 bond payments
starting, the ones that were approved
this year. These projects have been
included in the capital plan that was
approved a couple of weeks ago. Um and
some of those major projects again just
include the work to implement a new the
implement the new master parks plan um
uh some of the work of implementing
vision zero renovations needed for the
operations center um and other things
that you have seen in that capital plan.
And because we now have a capital plan,
we'll be reporting on these projections
much more regularly, quarterly actually.
Um and you'll see the capital budget
debt servicing projections start to show
up in the operating expense projections
as well.
All right. And as a final slide
regarding the numbers, I want to show
the projections over the next 10 years.
Um, so this is this is um very much
projections. It's 10 years, so it's it's
hard to say that this is this is not set
in stone by any means. Um, but this is
at this time assuming no additional tax
increases. So this is not including any
sort of real estate or earned income tax
increases.
Um again these are very much
projections. I wanted to point out that
even with increased debt payments for
the 2025 bond which were not included in
the projections from last year um that
we were working on our fund balance
which is the cash reserve the bottom
line there um uh remains at 15% through
um while increasing other expenses based
on on salary increases medical pension
um etc. So our goal is to keep and
you'll see this in the policy is to keep
the cash reserve between 15 and 20%.
Ideally on the higher end of that um so
this means that we will have some work
to do in the next few years to continue
to try to keep the expenses down. Um but
it also isn't unreachable unreachable to
remove these deficits in the upcoming
years. We won't necessarily need to
increase taxes to remove those deficits.
Um the projection uh if you recall
looked much bleeer last year um when we
were showing what would happen without
an earned income tax increase in 2025.
So I'm still feeling very positive um
that we can continue to work to
eliminate some of these deficits through
some of the efficiencies that we're
building now um and to ensure that we're
continuing to provide you know necessary
services without continuing to increase
taxes.
Um and finally before I stop for
questions I did want to ensure that you
have the full budget schedule for um for
uh any sort of input. So um from council
or from the public um we had a different
budget process last year because we were
voting on home rule um and we have a
different budget process this year
because the home rule charter is now in
effect. So, we will post the draft of
the budget online tomorrow. Um, and it
will be available for review starting
tomorrow through the time of adoption.
Um, budget questions and comments can be
posted on Engage Lancaster anytime
before December 1st. And we will respond
to them on on Engage Lancaster and we
will also respond at one of the various
meetings listed here um as as we get
them. So, as they come in,
um, and instead of having a full
Saturday budget hearing this year, as
we've done in the past, we're dividing
that into two evenings, um, as I've been
mentioning. So, the first one is on
October 21st, and that'll include
details from the departments that you
see here, administrative services, CPAD,
fire, and police. The second will be
held on November 18th, um, with the list
included here for that date. So, the
mayor's office, solicitor's office, and
elected officials, neighborhood
engagement, public works, and then the
utility funds are all of the enterprise
funds.
And again, I'll answer any questions
that come through the engagement, the
engage Lancaster platform at both of
those sessions. Then the first reading
of the budget ordinance um and the and
the real estate tax ordinance will be
November 25th with the second following
at the next regular council meeting,
which is December 9th. And in between
those, I'm available to answer any final
questions at the finance committee
meeting on Monday, December 1st.
And I will stop there.
>> Great. Thank you, Director Campbell, for
the presentation and uh appreciate you
and your team's hard work. As Mayor
Sarra mentioned in a previous meeting,
this is the earliest we've ever had a
budget presentation. So, very grateful
for the hard work. Uh I'll open it up to
the finance committee for any questions
or comments.
full counselors.
Thank you. Uh thank you Director
Campbell for um the detailed
presentation and look forward to getting
into these numbers a little further. I
have a very um brief question which is
just uh what is the uh status of the
financial statement audit for 2024?
Yeah, it's taking longer than we
expected, but we expect it to be done by
the end of October.
>> Wonderful. Thank you,
>> Councelor Med. Uh, thank you, Mr. Vice
President, and thank you, Director
Campbell, for the presentation. Um, I
just had two questions. First, with the
projections with some upcoming deficits
and some upcoming depletions of fund
balances, um, what are some ways that
the administration is going to be
keeping the increase in expenses
year-over-year down? um to avoid attacks
in Greece.
>> Yeah, it's a great question. Um so a
couple of the things that we're looking
at, one is um what I what I mentioned
which is around the healthc care costs.
That's always a huge driver for us. Um
and so I will be talking more about it
um on October 21st. So I'm going to say
come back then um to hear more about it.
But we are embarking on a pretty big
project for that. Um and the other piece
is that we have been um including some
new technology which costs some upfront
but we're hoping that that um also helps
us to improve efficiencies down the
road.
>> Thank you. And my final question was
regarding the earned income tax. I know
uh there was a previous discussion about
uh an exemption and what that would look
like um and the option for council to
have maybe a different a different way
we could allot those funds towards uh a
program that uh benefits lowincome
residents um is there any update on that
or should we suspect that in the next
meeting as well?
>> Um I would look to council to give some
um suggestions for that but I think
we're open to looking at that in the
budget. So,
>> and I think that there are some other
opportunities for funding the critical
repair uh critical repair program that
council has expressed interest in. Um,
we are having some internal
conversations about what that amount
might need to look like in order to
sustain the program year-over-year. And
we'll be coming back to council um with
further information uh in the I can't I
not exactly sure what meeting, but
sometime in November or December.
Thank you. So this current budget as
presented does not account for those
lost revenues.
>> The lost revenues
>> if there was an exemption I'm like
>> no because that um I believe at the
presentation that we had it was
demonstrated that the
um the effectively that it would cost
more to administer than the benefit
would provide for. And so no, there is
no um uh there this budget does not comp
contemplate any reduction in earned
income tax revenues as it relates to
that exemption. However, we do not want
to drop the thread of the conversation
related to the critical repair program
and as you know, we have allocated some
ARPA funds into that and that has really
bolstered that program over time and I
think that there's continued interest
from council is what I understand to um
seek additional funding for that
particular program. So, we will be
talking about that but outside of the
budget.
>> Thank you. And yeah, that was my
question. the total dollars, not as much
of if whatever program it may be, but
the total dollars being recognized in
the budget.
>> Yes. Thank you.
>> That concludes my questions. Thank you.
And thank you, Director Campbell.
>> Thank you, Council Med. And just add to
that, I have had conversations with
Director Campbell around uh coming back
to council before the end of the year to
uh discuss the tax exemption again. So,
uh in a future date, we'll have another
presentation regarding the logistics of
a tax exemption and some potentially
other ideas. As Director Campbell
mentioned, this is this budget is not
final. There are still opportunities to
uh to make some changes. So, uh look
forward to hearing some some of those
ideas as we move forward. Um Council
President,
>> thank you. Uh Director Campbell, uh the
10-year projection page. So, we've seen
this again and again and again, and this
year we have the revenue also includes
greater earned income tax. So, in the
past, these projections have always
assumed that we did there's no change.
So, uh, real estate or, uh, property
taxes were flat. I'm assuming that also
means that these projections mean that
the, uh, earned income tax is flat, so
it doesn't change. Or does this assume
the 5% growth or does is assume
essentially no growth from here?
>> Um, it assumes I believe this is a 3%
growth when you want to put 5% in, but
it does assume a a slight growth. So
like a conservative
amount of growth but not necessarily
what we've seen for that category.
>> Correct. Well,
>> or that we believe we'll see for that
category.
>> As I was mentioning last year, it
compounds a little bit because we have
increased the fee or the the um tax rate
this year. Um so it's going to it's
going to show a higher amount in the
budget.
>> Thank you for helping me understand
that.
Thank you, Council President. Any
additional questions or comments from
council.
Great. Um, at this time, prior to
calling for a motion on the bills, I'll
open the floor for public comment. Um,
as it relates to bill number 11 or bill
number 12.
Any public comment?
and you may just need to turn that on.
Great. Thank you. Hello, Tony Dastra,
700 block of New Holland Avenue. Um,
first I want to thank you councelor Amed
for mentioning the tax exemption. Uh,
and I think that the city needs to focus
on giving that relief directly to the
residents of the city, not circling it
through another program. Uh, I
understand that there is some expense in
the administrative cost to administer
such a program, but we're talking about
$300,000 of the $15 some million dollars
the city gets in revenue total. So, it's
less than 2% of the current revenue that
we're receiving from income tax and then
on top of the general operating fund
budget, it's pennies on the dollar. So,
our poorest residents deserve that
direct relief and I want to thank you
for continuing to speak on that. Uh and
then just for the record because it's a
uh touches on some subject of later
tonight, um the police is the largest
part of our budget. The pension is the
largest part of uh the pensions
management we have to do in the long
term. And so I hope we can look forward
to more efforts concerted by the
government to integrate the trust in our
community into the police department.
Thank you.
>> Thank you, Mr. Der. Any additional
public comment?
Good evening.
>> Good evening, Jessica Lopez.
>> Hey, my turn on there.
>> All right, Jessica Lopez, Lancaster City
resident. Um
my question isn't for now, but later on
down the line when um we start to
increase our taxes and start to hit
people who are not doing it this year,
but as the budget changes, it's going to
affect people who make less more than
it'll affect people who make more in the
city. So the question is, are we going
to later on decide to decrease our
police budget and protect the actual
residents of the city or are we going to
cut community engagement and housing
programs instead of cutting our police
budget when our wages won't be increased
later on
and it doesn't balance out
appropriately?
Happy to try to answer that. Director
Campbell. Yeah. Um so the projections
that were shown there were just
projections assuming that expenses
steadily increase. Um every year council
is tasked with passing the budget. So we
would go through this process every year
and have to either make tough decisions
if needed to cut expenses or um based on
revenues maybe not have to cut expenses.
>> And that's understandable. The question
is, is the council actually going to
make those tough decisions and cut the
police budget instead of cutting the
services that help our community?
>> Yeah, that would be dependent on that
council.
>> Council Rio President,
>> just to speak to that question, I will
say that we have done a um a staffing
study for the police and have decreased
the number of officers that we've
budgeted for um by a pretty significant
amount this year. Um, so I will say that
we have taken those steps to make sure
we're right sized and I think that
demonstrates the city's commitment to
making sure that we're doing that
continually in the future. So whatever
right size may mean, we we have looked
at that and I would hope that future
councils and administrations would
continue to do that.
>> Thank you.
>> Any additional public comment?
My name is Matthew Barton.
>> You might need to slide that back.
>> And it's okay to leave that on. Thank
you.
>> Yeah,
>> there it goes.
>> Should be good. Yep.
>> Thank you. Um, so you you said that
you've done the the work to justify the
size of the police department. Is that
data publicly available or can it be
made publicly available to show the
justification for the size of the city?
>> I believe that the staffing study
information is lives on somewhere on the
city website. It's certainly documented
in the meetings that we had um that we
discussed it, but I can't say for
certain exactly where that is today
besides those meetings. So I would just
say that uh I would echo that to see
that disproportionate amount of the
budget dedicated to police when we have
2% I believe it was for community
engagement 12% per for public works. We
can all look around our city and and I
think we can all agree that it needs
more than 12% of our budget in the
infrastructure.
Um I I I see idle police cars
consistently. I see multiple police cars
for basic traffic stops. Uh, and I have
a hard time believing that those kinds
of things were found in the
justification for the size of our police
department when we're committing only
12% to public works and 2% to public
engagement.
[Applause]
>> Thank you.
Any additional public comment?
Great. Thank you, Director Campbell.
With that uh with that I will motion to
move bill number 11 2025 to the first
reading for a first reading on November
25th.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second. All those
in favor?
>> I
second. I'll motion to move
administration bill number 12 uh to the
for first reading on November 25th.
We have a motion and a second. All those
in favor?
>> I
>> I. That concludes the finance committee.
Council President.
>> Thank you very much, Councelor Royo.
We'll now move into our community
planning committee. Uh handing it over
then to councelor Craig.
>> Thank you, Council President.
>> There it
go. Okay. Great. Thank you. Um we have
five items on the agenda this evening.
First of them being um the review of the
historical commission recommendation for
an after the fact demolition and new
construction at 444 West Lemon Street.
Um is there someone here from the
historical commission?
>> Yes.
>> That'll be
>> that's fine.
Good evening.
>> Good evening. Christopher Peters, chair
of the historical commission. With me
tonight is um Vice Chair Danielle and
former vice chair uh Steve Funk as well.
So, as was mentioned, there was um a
proposal brought before us. It was after
the fact demolition and new
construction. Uh this is over on Lemon
Street. And um what occurred and I trust
maybe you've driven by and seen it.
There's a stretch of two and a half
story uh row homes that have a dormer.
There's 13 in a row and in fact on that
those couple blocks there's very there's
some continuity there with 14 in a row
and even more on that street. So what
happened is the um gable roof was
removed, dorma was removed and a new
basically third floor was constructed.
Uh we did not see this um until last
month after it was constructed. So we're
recommending to the city council to deny
certificate of appropriateness and we
based it on uh secretary of interior
standards 25 and 9. If you don't mind,
I'll read just a couple quotes there. Uh
the historic character of property shall
be retained and preserved. The removal
of historic materials or alteration of
features and spaces that characterize a
property shall be avoided. That's number
two. Number five, distinct features,
finishes, construction techniques um
shall be preserved. And number nine,
exter regarding exterior alterations
specifically shall not destroy his
historic materials that characterize uh
the property. The uh secretary of the
interior standards actually has some
recommendations when it comes to dormers
and that's specifically what's going on
uh with this uh application. Um,
primarily one of their recommendations
is historic dormers that are part of the
original design should not be altered in
scale or form. So that dormer was
removed, the gable roof was removed, and
an entire third floor um was put in its
place. Um, so there's a series of other
recommendations, but I can um leave it
at that and open it up for questions,
but that's why we recommended um uh
denial of this application.
Are there any questions from the
committee?
>> Go ahead.
>> Hi, Council Craig. I believe we also
have uh the gentleman that is the
property owner here. Are we able to hear
from property owner as well?
>> Thank you, Council Craig.
Hi, my name is Nathan Charles. Um, I've
I live on uh currently live on 425 North
Prince Street. I previously lived on 333
South Prince Street and I'm hoping to
move into 444 West Lemon. Um, so it's
it's kind of a I'm I'm quite surprised
to be here. Um, I thought we were, you
know, doing everything right. We have a
permit. Um, so I was very surprised to,
you know, essentially get after the
fact, um, notification, uh, kind of
designation of this historic review. So,
um, I have with me, uh, Jesse Pelman,
who is, um, kind of the builder. We've
been working together on this this
concept and idea for a very long time.
This is a fairly ambitious project. Um I
have u been living in the city for many
many years and um periodically I've gone
through the exercise of I should buy a
house and then I go look at the houses
housing inventory and then it's like I
should not buy a house. Um I get very
discouraged when I see bad flips um and
and you know properties that need a lot
of renovation that um I then compete
with flippers for. So this was the first
opportunity I felt like I had. I now
have some means. I can now make a deep
investment uh in in Lancaster City and
actually build a house that's very, you
know, very small um uh by I mean we're
not really increasing the size. We
pushed up uh the roof a little bit, but
it's only the front. So effectively,
we've turned a two-story house into two
and a half story house. Um
and so this is a very typical um city
dwelling. And the hope is to get be this
will be the first uh house in Lancaster
County that will u meet the passive
house standard. Um Jesse, do you want to
add a few comments?
>> My name is Jesse Pullman. I run Long
View Structures. Our shop is on uh 400
block of South Prince Street. We do
quite a bit of work in town. Um and
would also sort of say first off, thank
you to all of you for engaging in
conversations. One of the goals of this
project uh is precisely to engage and to
create dialogue around what housing can
be uh most specifically what housing in
urban environments in infill and what
the reutilization of existing housing
stock could look like. So uh just for
the sake of our sort of records uh
keeping and our analysis of how we got
to this point, Nate alluded to being
somewhat surprised uh to being here. We
submitted uh a permit application as we
do for all of our projects along with
building elevations, floor plans, and a
very short narrative of what the project
was going to entail. We had multiple
back and forths with uh city staff
including the inspector who was doing
the plan review at the time. Had
follow-up conversation with zoning
specifically as it related to at that
time what was a proposed roof deck on
the Lemon Street facade. There were 3D
models that were associated with the
permit submitt that showed what we were
doing along with the extensive energy
modeling that we were pursuing. So the
after the-act characterization,
while I fully acknowledge we are now
evaluating a completely built out
structure that is effectively from the
exterior done, it was in no way intended
to be nor was it an after the fact
submitt. Um we then followed up as the
plan was developing, as we were in
process, and as we were doing deep
energy modeling. Uh we resubmitted plans
and elevations uh that represent the
current asbuilt condition to the city
and to the city inspectors for
additional review and for comment. And
receiving none and following through
with site inspections, we carried on
with our work with the work as it had
been permitted uh and authorized by the
city. So that's our our background. It
is not um necessarily an after the fact
in so much as we were trying to skirt or
get around this opportunity. Uh as I
mentioned, we are looking for dialogue
and for community and interaction. Um,
one of the reasons that we have ended
with the design that is currently up for
debate is, as Nathan referenced, uh, our
desire to reach a passive house
certification, which is an energy
metric, uh, just an exceptionally
miserly, uh, energy requirement for
performance. It is one of the most
stringent building standards and
requirements that exists. There are
currently none in the area that meet it.
there are specifically none in the area
that meet it in an urban retrofit common
wall application that we are attempting
to undertake. So the decision-making
process and matrix that we entered into
was robust, it was intentional and it
was thorough and we did our best to try
to engage with uh city officials as we
initiated the process and as it's gone
throughout. So, one of the pieces that
has come up for debate is how we
hyperinsulate
and provide for future housing what a
really basically zero energy house in
the city can look like. And one of the
demands is insulation. So, I'll get a
little technical. Please interrupt me.
Ask questions at any point. But the
existing dormer in question was a vinyl
clad uh vinyl-sided dormer with what we
call cheek walls that were about an inch
and a half thick of no insulation and
wood only. The window in question was
already replaced with a vinyl window.
There was no wood mill work. The back uh
roof of this structure had already been
removed. The stairs and access were
non-code compliant, unsafe, and the roof
was structurally unsound. Um, not that
it was uninhabitable, not that it was
way outside the bounds of normal city
housing stock, but this I want to just
set the character was not a particularly
uh architecturally historic property in
so much as the materials that were
removed were of high value either
monetarily or necessarily
architecturally. I do absolutely agree
with the historic commission that we did
interrupt the block. Um so I will not
dispute or try to uh counter the
argument that we did break the
continuity of a 14 dormer stretch.
Again, part of what we were looking to
do is start dialogue. So I have a crew
there that works every day and there's
hardly a day that goes by where somebody
doesn't stop and say, "What's happening?
I've never seen this. Tell me about the
project that's going on." We've hosted
uh regional events that is also um
looking for the future of housing, how
we can do um housing in Lancaster well,
properly, efficiently. Um so while we
are in conflict with the uh historic
commission's report, we got here
somewhat unintentionally. Um but at the
same time we got here very much on
purpose because we made uh a decision
based on what we believe represents a
possibility for moving forward. Um and
the architecture style of how we do that
on the next one is certainly up for
debate and had we gone through the
process or been directed through the
process at the initial plan submitt or
if the city had requested additional
feedback or information we would have
gladly engaged at that time. So happy to
do that now. Um, I've talked a lot at
you. I really truly do want to have this
primarily be conversation and dialogue,
but I want it to be understood in the
context that this was a fully permitted,
fully green lighted city project um that
we are doing with the best intention of
both city block, city future and housing
in mind. Um, so the characterization of
after the fact I I bristle a little bit.
Um, and I also just want to characterize
that we did not
the vast majority of my company's work
isn't historic preservation. So, you
know, we we do we fall into these camps
where the world of preservation isn't
inherently one of the most responsible
and sustainable ways to build. Part of
the driver for this project was can we
take that same mentality and push the
envelope to this next level of potential
development and can we get to one of the
highest certifications that's out there
in a Lanster city home. Um rather than
it's much easier out in a cornfield. Um
we learned that today during some
testing. Uh you know it's a very
difficult very stringent um project that
we're trying to
>> Thank you. Thank you. Um, so you said
you mentioned that um, you've been a
contractor in Lancaster City for quite a
while.
>> Yep.
>> And it never dawned on you to maybe go
before the historical commission or
check with the historical commission
because, you know, a large portion of
our city is historical.
>> Absolutely. And we routinely run into
Suzanne. Um, we looked at where this
property was. It's an eclectic block.
It's outside of the harb. All of these
played into Nate's desire to purchase
the home. And
I don't want to we submit a lot of
permits. Um we are very much under the
guidance of city permit clerk and city
permit offices to follow their leading
in their guidance. Um I we are often
I can tell you anecdotal stories where
we conflict with um guidance because all
of the code books are guidelines open to
interpretation. So I view my role as
submitting all of the information at
hand and then having that disseminated
properly to the folks who need to review
it and who need to stamp it and who need
to certify it. And we do that to the
best of our ability. So we never
withhold information. We present it all
out there for review and then we respond
accordingly.
>> Okay. Thank you so much for the
information. Um my primary concern is
that I mean you there wasn't any thought
of considering going through the
historical commission
or the historical review board to you
know you know to look over your plans
for the property and you know since
you yourself said that you I mean you've
been a contractor in Lancaster city for
the longest time
it would stand to reason that we might
want to do that before we move forward.
>> And that was part of the reason we
actually did the followup plan
submission midway through. So, we did go
back, we called in and said, "Hey, who
who wants to see the plan review?" We
were directed to give it to the
inspector who was going to be doing the
plan reviews. That's where we sent it.
And so, yeah, I I acknowledge that it
did not make it to Suzanne. that was not
our intention to and withhold it from
the historic commission or any other
body that could get there. Um,
>> thank you. Are there any other questions
from the committee?
>> Council Craig.
>> Um, thank you for the explanation. Um,
curious about a couple things and I'm
not sure who in this room could
potentially answer this, but
specifically about the process. So when
you guys applied for the permits and
received these permits, you guys
submitted drawings and set the
expectation of what was going to be done
and I'm assuming what was applied for
was completed
>> that. Well, yes. So with the
resubmission, sure. So, we got a permit.
>> Mhm.
>> We realized partway through actually
somewhat in response to uh city
infrastructure planning and looking at
the utilization of upper level stories
um and the move to capture additional
living space and density. We said what's
a responsible use? We have this outofode
compliance space that we can utilize. uh
and partly as a reaction to that decided
to enlarge that third floor and then
resubmitted plans and elevations showing
existing conditions the initial plan
that had been submitted and the revised
plan that showed the new projections and
elevations. So it did come back through
for review to the city.
>> Gotcha. And at that point it the permit
was approved with the re after the
resubmission. the permit had already
been approved prior to that and we
resubmitted and said is there anything
that we need to do with this
>> and got no response and so we continued
and have had inspections.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. I think for me personally, Council
Craig, I'm I think just from a process
standpoint, I have questions around if a
permit was issued with the expectation
of this
project happening in the way that it
happened. uh what happens with the after
the-act determination? So, if the
project's already completed, what
happens now if council were not to
approve this to move forward
and
>> maybe that's a general question for
someone else to answer as well.
>> Yeah, Mr. Funk. Sure, you can step up to
the mic. Yes.
>> Hi, Mr. Funk. Yeah.
if this is on. Uh I'm Steve Funk, U
member of the historical commission.
>> You can feel free to move that up and
down too. The you can feel free to move
that mic stand up and down too if it
>> is low or if it's on or not on. I'm not
sure.
>> There it goes. Yeah. Okay. Uh regarding
the permit, u I don't know if you've all
seen a permit application. Uh, it
includes boxes that you check that
describe the different types of work
that are that may occur under the
permit. Um, I assume the applicant
filled out the permit application. They
failed to check the box for demolition
or addition. Um, and then the permit was
actually listed as a permit for interior
renovation. Um, that's why it wasn't
flagged and sent to the historical
commission first. Um, you know, I'm
hesitant to assign blame to that,
especially because no one from the the
building department is here to uh state
their position, but there were some
problems with the application and with
the permit that was um that was issued
for interior renovation only, and this
obviously was not interior renovation.
>> It did reference full window
replacement. It had three-dimensional
models of the exterior. There's also a
checklist on the front that we filled
out in its entirety. Nowhere on the
checklist does it ask us to go to the
historic commission. So, we did fill out
a checklist.
>> Well, yeah, that's that's not on it's
not on the application. Yeah,
>> sure. It is up to the building official
to determine whether it goes to the
historical commission or not to
determine what's reviewable.
>> Um,
>> but in the historical commission's, you
know, view, the permit was issued in
error. uh it was an administrative
error, a clerical error. You know, it
was the wrong kind of permit that was
issued uh for obviously an addition, you
know, demolition and a building addition
uh that's not listed on the permit or
the application.
>> Thank you.
>> Are there any further questions from um
from the committee or full counsel?
Mhm.
>> Council Craig, uh perhaps um a staff
member could answer this question, but
just logistically, what does it mean to
deny an application after the fact?
Could someone just talk to perhaps
someone from the the commission? Chris,
thank you.
>> Good evening everyone. Um I first of all
I
f first of all uh I would like to say
this is always a bad situation when we
have uh construction that was done uh in
error. I I do agree uh with Mr. Funk
that uh there was uh an administrative
error that was involved in this
situation. I uh we're also taking a
closer look at um how exactly uh this
occurred. I do think there was were some
abnormalities with uh with the
application itself. Um we're going to
take a closer look at that. I also have
emails from uh as early as June where
this was uh this problem was flagged
among staff and I believe that it may
have been raised uh uh with the
applicant. Uh they can speak to this but
as early as August. So I'm I'm very uh
confused about why the work continued uh
after that point. Uh I would also uh I'm
going to check on this but I would take
a little bit of issue with what Mr. Funk
said. Um we do have uh we do have pro uh
protocols internally to try to make sure
that we uh flag when something is
reviewed needs to be reviewed by the
historical commission. However, it's the
responsibility of the property owner to
determine uh if they need to go before
the historical commission. And
unfortunately, even if a building permit
has been issued in error, um that does
not necessarily um absolve the applicant
of needing to get uh that approval. So,
I I really feel bad for this situation
that work has occurred and money has
been spent. Uh again, we try to avoid
that at all costs. At the same time, uh
this is a very egregious example of
abuse of not abuse, I'm sorry. uh of
being out of character with the
historical architecture on the block. Um
I really appreciate uh uh what these
gentlemen are trying to do from a green
design standpoint, but that
sustainability sustainable design can be
done um within the confines of good
historical architecture and good
historical design. Uh I think one of the
things that I would like to uh share
with you all is a a photo of the uh
building uh the construction if you have
not seen it yet. Um it is unfortunately
um it really does make a huge impact on
the block. Uh I'm happy to do some
additional analysis for you all with
respect to what happened with the permit
process, but I think that there are also
uh policy precedent questions here um
and and significant uh historic historic
architectural loss on this block if this
were to uh stand. Thank you.
>> Thank you, Director Bill. Um,
speaking to the historical commission
right now,
is there a resolution? Is there
something that can be done
in lie of what they have?
I guess I'll say we're tasked to review
applications whether they meet uh the
secretary of the tier group standards
and the design standards and we're not
really tasked with providing design
solutions or recommendations at this
point in time and I would find that
pretty difficult at this with with this
application.
>> Thank you. Yeah.
>> Are there any further questions from
council as a whole? Councelor
Mid.
>> Uh, thank you, Councelor Craig. Um, uh,
and I guess my only question would be to
Councelor Craig's point, and given this
is after the fact, um, are they expected
to return it to its original state?
The historical commission just looks at
what is presented to us. So we were
presented with a demolition request
after the fact after it was already
demolished and then with the design if
it came to us like just as a blueprint
we would deny it. So that's why we
denied it as built. Um, and and I will
say because my background is in
preservation construction, it is very
easy to figure out if a building's in
the harp or in the in the historical
commission, I often will just go on the
city website. You can type in the
address and see what zoning and what um
criteria it you're that each address
needs. So, that that's something that is
not very hard to figure out if you need
to do.
>> Councelor Craig, if I may.
>> Absolutely.
>> Thank you. Um, I want to recognize um
the members of the historical commission
for their work and understand that their
role is really to review the um
secretary of interior standards and this
presents a really interesting and unique
challenge and and it's not one that's
entirely uncommon uh to city council. I
remember a case in which um we we've
talked about dormers before. We've
talked about uh uh roofing materials uh
etc etc. But this is a a a substantial
change to the pattern of the dormers
along this particular block of uh of
Lemon Street. And um and it is akin to
sort of seeing a group of row homes
where all the porches are open and then
there's that one that's enclosed right
in the middle of the block. Um and so I
I I also want to acknowledge the
ambitiousness of the certification
program that you're going through.
um and the efforts that you're taken to
do something that's very unique in the
city from a sustainability and um um a
net zero uh energy project. Um, I also
acknowledge and I I've never met you
before, Jesse, but I'm familiar that
your business is located here in the
city and I do see Long View structure
signs um throughout the city and I know
that um that you know you are
conscientious in the work that you're
doing. There's a lot of different things
that have happened in in this um in this
particular circumstance. What I'm going
to suggest um to uh to to you councelor
Craig is a motion to table because I
think that we need to have there's a if
council is going to pursue a path in
which there needs to be um uh the the
the roof uh the dormer needs to be
returned to its original intention.
There are procedures I believe as it
relates to the affordability and an
applicant can um share that information
with council in terms of what the cost
estimates are and have more information
from which to make a decision. I would
also say that it's important for council
to consider you know the um the internal
operations of how this um you know in
terms of the permit review and so on.
And so I will be following up with our
internal department um as well um in
terms of um just the check boxes. But
this isn't just about the checkbox. This
is about a a house that is going to
ostensibly be forever changed by uh by
by these renovations. as good
intentioned and as um
you know forward thinking that they they
are in terms of what you're trying to
accomplish. So that's my recommendation.
I probably could have gotten to that
more quickly, but thank you for hanging
with me as I'm a little thinking a
little bit out loud.
>> Thank you so much, Mayor.
>> Councelor Craig, if I may or sorry, go
ahead.
>> Oh, councelor colleagues.
>> Well, thank you, Councelor Greg. I'm
wondering uh I don't I'm not sure who
would answer that question. Uh would it
be possible to submit a new application
if they follow the historical
commission's guidelines?
Would you gentlemen be able to submit a
new application?
>> We could submit a new application. One
of the difficulties is
we're done. Um I would just go back to
the comment why work continued. Um work
has not continued since we were notified
of the issue. So in August we were given
permission to continue and carry on with
interior work and non-visible work. We
have not done anything on that front
Lemon Street facing side. So again we
are doing our best to comply with the
information that we are receiving from
the city. the um what I would say
potential difficulty in the new
application is the decisions that we've
made as part of this project are not
easily undoable um from either just a
logistical standpoint or a financial
standpoint. Um the window that in
question that faces Lemon Street is
imported from Austria. It is not a
run-of-the-mill window. It is a deep
investment in what good future housing
uh is going to look like in terms of
technology. So we can argue the
architecture, we can argue the aesthetic
all day long. Um, but the difficulty
will be how we go backwards and still
use the appropriate technology to to
meet these needs. So we could certainly
resubmit it would represent significant
time and financial impacts to the client
and if we have to, you know, it's an
active work site. Um, so we were hoping
to be able to continue forward. Um, the
city has made us aware that previously
they said we could continue interior
work, but we were just notified that
when we tried to schedule an interior
inspection that they would not inspect
until after this meeting. So, we have a
unoccupied city house sitting mid
construction here as well, which is
again represents a both time and and
finance constraint to the client.
>> Yeah. But it's also important to
u follow the historical commission's
recommendations in order to uh preserve
the historical aspects of the city's
infrastructure.
>> Mhm.
>> And again I I do not dispute that. I
look at how we got to the eclectic block
that this is where across the way we
have distinctly different architecture
on the book ends of the corner blocks.
It's an entirely different vernacular.
If you turn the corner, uh, we work on a
property on Langster Avenue that's a
church that's now a residence that's a
hyper modern interior. I think part of
the beauty of a living vibrant city is
the diversity in the block. Um, and so
while I do fully acknowledge the loss of
the repeating pattern of the dormer, I
would again couch it in that there was
not particular significance to it as an
individual, certainly to the block as a
whole. I would love to look at that as
an opportunity. Um and if we need to you
know do a better job of education and
and inviting people to participate in
that conversation that's you know one of
the goals that we are looking to do here
um is to make this be something and it
it won't be for everybody's taste you
know some like Victorian houses some
colonial shaker
>> I think that I would recommend um
console Greg to table this um
for now until you and uh you guys and
the historical commissions finally come
ground on that.
>> Um,
>> thank you.
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> Thank you, Councelor Craig. Um, I just
want to make a comment because this very
interesting situation that we're in. So,
when I want to be empathetic to the fact
that uh it was mentioned that clerical
error was made. So, I have um it's a
little frustrating to feel that we're
going to put the onus on a property
owner uh to um a resident to have to
correct that when uh it was something on
our process that potentially could have
prevented this. Um, the other thing that
I do want to mention, why I think there
I have a deep appreciation for our
city's historical infrastructure. I
think the reality as well is that there
are numerous conversations that are
happening throughout our community
around housing affordability, energy
consumption, energy affordability. Um,
and it's going to take innovative
solutions to solve those challenges. So
um
right now we have this tension between a
historic housing stock uh which you know
yes we we definitely should preserve and
um also the need for innovation
innovative solutions around housing
affordability. Uh so it's interesting
that this specific property um also is
demonstrating this new idea that can
save anywhere from 70 to 90% in energy
costs which I find fascinating for a
city that is suffering through a housing
crisis and housing excuse me a housing
affordability crisis and energy
consumption can be um uh a big part of
that. So um yeah I just I want to make
that comment. I think uh given the fact
that this is done, I would also uh
encourage and recommend Mayor Sarra's
recommendation around tableabling this
uh to ensure that you know we can come
up with a with a good solution and move
forward that honors um our city's
historic uh integrity but then also
understands that you know there are
opportunities for new innovative
solutions to uh housing affordability
here.
>> Thank you counselor advice.
Are there any questions or comments from
the public?
>> This is on.
>> Okay. It's actually at my level. Um I'm
Susie Hoover. I have a house at 204 East
King Street, uh 1787.
Uh when I redid that house a number of
years ago, um people tried to sell me
replacement windows, this that and the
other thing. And um I retained the
original windows. I had them redone and
not even well painted and that sort of
thing. Uh a specialty uh insulation
window on a storm window on that. Um and
um I would say with an old house that
age and I took efforts with the best
heating, the elast uh air conditioning
that I could, uh my um
uh utility bills on that house are very
low. And people come into my house and
they tell me how incredibly quiet it is
for being right on the frontage of East
King Street, which it is. Um and so I
think there are ways of accomplishing
um staying historic uh with materials um
that uh are very conducive uh to these
type of renewal of historic homes
without making major uh deviation uh
from uh regulations for historic homes.
Thank you.
>> Thank you, Miss Hoover.
Tony Dashra, 700 block of New Holland
Avenue. I I don't think the city's
process failed them here. Uh, as Mr. Fun
pointed out, and I get it, it was a it
was a check mark, but right now we're
living in a country where people are
being deported over check marks on
forms.
This is honestly a a situation which I
understand the complications but
something was filled out wrong and the
process was followed in correctly and
that stuff happens. Uh I think we do
need to be mindful of our historic
architecture. But I've even said to some
people like we don't need to preserve
every single house in Langster City for
its historic nature if we're trying to
be a city that develops. So I think me
as a member of the public I'm open to
change. I don't understand the full
context of your situation, but I want to
defend the city here and say like I
don't think that their process was
wrong. It this was a I I'm going to
assume to be a genuine error. Um and I
hope for you all the best in navigating
this going forward, but
sorry.
>> Thank you, Mr. Dastra. Are there any
further questions from the public or
comments?
hearing none. Um I'd like to make a
motion to table this um resolution
their historical review until we can
investigate much further.
>> All those in favor
>> I
>> I thank you. Thank you gentlemen.
All right. The next item on our agenda
this evening is um administration
resolution number 65205
um authorizing a cooperation agreement
for for grant funding with the Lancaster
County Housing and Redevelopment
Authority.
Director Campbell,
Tina Campbell.
I promise I will not talk as long as I
did when I was up here before. Um, but
this is a required agreement from the
Pennsylvania Office of the Budget for
the Redevelopment Assistance Capital
Program Grant or RACK P. Um, this is a
grant that the redevelopment authority,
the Langster County redevelopment
authority was awarded for the
reconstruction that's happening at the
former Redmond site at 800 South Queen
Street. Um, for RACKP grants, a
municipality or a municipal authority
must apply for the funding. Um, so even
if it is a community benefit
organization or a developer, it must go
through a municipality or a municipal
authority. Generally the municipality
where the organization is is located or
where the project is located will apply.
Um but in this case and and in other
cases too the city has um asked Langster
County redevelopment authority to apply
just based on capacity to do those
applications. Um so the grant
application was awarded by the office of
the budget the Pennsylvania office of
the budget back in 2023 I believe. Um,
and because the host municipality, so
the host municipality of the project, in
this case us, we were not the applicant,
the office of the budget requires a
cooperative agreement between the
applicant and the municipal authority
that's doing um the project or that's
that's uh um
um working with the grant. So, it's a
it's basically an agreement that should
the authority not do what they're
supposed to do to ensure prompt payment
of the grant to the um uh to the
organization that's supposed to be
receiving it, the city needs to work
with the authority to ensure that that
payment goes where it should be going.
It doesn't obligate us to actually pay
funds or really indeed incur any
financial transactions, even a pass
through transaction. So, it's no
financial transactions for the city.
We've signed this agreement for a few
other grants. most recently was last
year um for the LGH expansion which has
been completed. We've never needed to
enforce or do anything with this
agreement. The authority is very well
verssed in managing RACKP funding. Um
they handle a lot more than we do each
year for the county.
>> Thank you, Director Campbell. Are there
any questions about this resolution from
the committee?
>> No. No questions or comments from the
public? Hearing
none, I'll make a motion to move
resolution 65 to full counsel on the
>> 14th. Second.
>> Say again.
>> Okay. All those in favor?
>> I
>> Thank you. The next item on our agenda
this evening is resolution 66.
And I'm noticing that 66 and 67 are
local shares accounts. Is it okay if we
do them together?
>> We might.
>> We do.
>> We do. Okay. All right. Authorizing the
application to local shares account
program by tenfold.
>> Hi, my name is Dan Mesher. I'm the
director of TLC, which stands for
transitional living center. It's a
program of Tfold uh operating out of 105
East King Street. currently uh offsite
during renovation. Uh but
>> Dan, I'm sorry. You may need to hit that
button to turn your mic on. You're very
good at projecting, but I'm just Thank
you.
>> All right. Great. Um I'm here on behalf
of Tenfold requesting $100,000 from the
local shares account to purchase a 15
passenger van. Um this van will directly
support client services in a number of
ways. Um, it will serve the
transportation needs of Tenfold's
shelter and housing stability programs.
At any given time, there are 190
households in Tenfold's programs that
could benefit from uh, transportation.
Uh, in each of these programs, uh, case
managers provide services to individuals
and families experiencing homelessness
in Lancaster County. Many of these
households face transportation barriers,
limiting access to things like
employment opportunities, health care,
housing appointments, and food banks.
Uh, a 15 passenger van would also serve
as a means for households without
transportation to access TLC, emergency
shelter, when they cannot get there on
their own. Um, we also envision using
this for logistical supports as well,
moving supplies between different sites.
um and really to facilitate and uh
building positive community and positive
experiences among our case managers and
and clients and and in the households
themselves. Um having the ability to
take people on educational outings, um
attending local events, volunteering, um
all of which promote connections,
strengthen relationships, and and build
community. We believe that a 15
passenger van aligns with the LSA's goal
of enhancing community well-being and
infrastructure and it will allow Tensold
staff to safely and reliably transport
clients to critical destinations which
we believe will shorten the length of
time people experience homelessness and
that we feel like is a win for
everybody.
>> Thank you.
Um, I'm going to ask if Director
Campbell can come and give us a brief
overview so that we can just review what
local shares are
and where they come from.
>> I'm going to actually just introduce you
to Jen Arontes who is our community fund
development manager and she handles all
of the uh LSA grants. So, she's going to
give you a little over.
>> Wonderful.
>> Perfect. Um again I'm Jen and um the
purpose of the statewide LSA program is
to reinvest gaming funds um into
projects in the communities to improve
quality of life across Pennsylvania. Um
so specifically these grants range
anywhere from $25,000 to $1 million and
there's no local match required. Funding
can be used to support public
infrastructure, community facilities,
equipment, vehicle purchases, demolition
and planning and design work. So, a lot
of the benefits that comes to the
communities that apply and receive LSA
funding, um, it brings outside
investment into projects that might
otherwise be unfunded, improves
neighborhood facilities and services,
and creates opportunities for
partnerships specifically because the
city needs to apply um for any
nonprofits or other organizations who
are interested in these programs. Um, so
since 2022 when we were first able to
apply for these grants, um, we as a city
have submitted 30 applications, 11 have
been awarded and we're still waiting for
2024 applications. In total, Lancaster
City has received 5.9 million in awarded
dollars through the LSA program and in
2025, we're expecting to submit 11 more.
>> Thank you so much. Um, are there any
questions from the committee on the
local shares?
Council Craig, I have one one
clarification that might be important
context. Um, also thank you for your
application. I think it's a very worthy
project. Um, but just about the local
shares process. Although we uh submit
the application on behalf of the
organizations. Uh, do we have any sort
of fiduciary responsibility or oversight
if the they are to be awarded?
>> We do not. So we sign with any awarded
organization. we sign anou with them
basically stating that we are there for
um support for grant support and that
all of the then reimbursements come
through us um but we are not we are not
the the owners of those dollars it comes
from the state directly
>> thank you
>> wonderful
um I'm going to make a motion that we
move um resolution 66 to full counsel on
the 14th
>> second
>> all those in favor
>> I Thank you. Thank you. Um the next item
on our agenda is resolution 67 2025
authorized an application to local
shares account program by the YWCA.
Good evening.
>> Good evening. Uh my name is Dana Clark.
I'm actually the architect for the Y
Forward renovations. I'm here on behalf
of Stacy tonight. She was able to make
it, but I want to thank council and the
mayor for allowing us this opportunity.
Um this is as you may know a
transformational
um project for the YW.C.A.
their historic building and quite
honestly that that corner of the city.
Uh at this point if you haven't been by
recently we're about 95% complete. Um if
you're looking for a historic building
with a facelift go check out this one.
Um, we're super excited for having been
able to remove the stair tower and
restore the facade of that building. So,
if you haven't been by, please, please
take a take a walk and take a look. I
have promised everyone on staff there
that they will be in before
Thanksgiving. If they don't, they
promised they would cook me. So, in our
in the next steps for this um in this
first there were two other previous
phases that we did some with LSA
funding. Um
this phase uh we were going to welcome
new tenants uh 17 we've added 17 units
of low-income housing and then
refurbished 12 existing residential
suites in the existing building. What
we're looking for now the request before
you is to support phase four which is
the last phase of this really ambitious
project. Um,
this last phase will renovate all the
additional residential suites that have
not been touched by any of the three
previous phases.
Um, it will enhance livability and
efficiency. Uh, we talked a little bit
about energy efficiency. It is key in
making an older building work well. Part
of what we're doing is increasing the
efficiency of all the units and phase 4
continues to do that on the fourth
floor, uh, which is the location of the
the remaining units that need to be
renovated.
The second floor, uh, another key
component is a childcare component. The
second floor is going to get reorganized
and renovated. Again, not only improved,
uh, utilities, HVAC, lighting, uh, but
also better layout to support more
programs for the daycare center. So,
we're excited. We're excited by that.
Um, it will increase the overall
capacity of the Y and its program, which
is something that they really do need.
um the first floor. So the phase four is
really the fourth floor, the second
floor and some additional work on the
fourth on the first floor. Um the work
on the first floor, if you guys have
been in there, you know there's there's
an old gymnasium that was in there
similar to what we did when we filled in
the old auditorium space. We're looking
to get more square footage in this urban
environment and there's nowhere for them
to go. So the best use of that existing
facility would be to add another floor
there. And again, this is all to
increase the childcare program. So all
the work that we're doing, I know
they'll be very excited to show you all
at the open house. All the work we're
doing is very sensitive to the historic
fiber inside the building and outside
the building. So um while it's, you
know, it's unfortunate to infill a
volume space, um I think in this
particular case it makes sense for the Y
and their programming. Um, and again,
the first floor layout, some of the
lobby, if you guys have been in the
lobby, you know, has had some less
sensitive work done to it. Uh, the last
piece of phase 4 is to take certain
portions of that lobby that are really
open to the public and for community use
and sort of restore those pieces back to
a more historically sensitive context.
So, uh, the full cost for phase 4 is
projected at 7 million. Uh, phase three
is going to finish, they've already
spent or will be spending at the end of
phase three 11 million. So, the Y has
invested significant resources not only
through grant programs like the LSA, but
you know, Stacy has done a phenomenal
job of of looking for other in other
forms of revenue to support the mission
and the programs at the Y. So, I was
pretty excited that she asked me to come
and and help with this one. You guys
have any questions?
>> Thank you. I have one question. How many
total units will be in the Y?
>> So, there's going to be on the I think
there are I knew you're going to ask me
that.
I'm going to guess and don't hold me to
this because it's I don't have my
drawings with me. I'm going to guess
there's an additional
18 additional 24 units on the fourth
floor that'll be wound into this. So
that takes it to
52 53. So um you know and they vary
there's all different types of units. So
we have accessible units. We have
essentially SRO units which think of old
style dorm rooms, right? Uh, some have
their some have little kitchenetses
inside, some have their own bathrooms
inside, some use a shared facility. So,
I think they're touching they're trying
to hit as many points of need as
possible. Um, and I think, you know, one
of the ways to to do that is if everyone
has a great room that they can call
their own, even if this has a shared
restroom, if you go through this, you'll
see the shared ref rooms are really
quite nice. So, I think they're doing
their best to expand the program and
accommodate as many folks as need their
help as possible. And they're doing it
with all different types of unit
configurations.
>> Thank you so much. Are there any
questions from the committee?
>> Councelor colleagues.
>> Thank you, councelor. Thank you for
being here tonight. And uh what can you
tell us uh about the timeline of this
project? So phase the pro the protection
for phase four.
>> Yeah because because phase three is like
I said is due to finish in November of
this year. Phase four uh this is one
piece of a larger puzzle as it relates
to funding. So I think her I think
Stacy's goals are to have drawings
underway in 2026 for phase 4 which would
put us into a 2027 start for phase 4.
So,
>> thank you.
>> Welcome.
>> Thank you, Councelor G.
>> Are there any further questions from
council as a whole? Coun questions or
comments?
>> Councelor Diaz.
>> Thank you, Councelor Craig. I just
wanted to uh commend you. Um I was a
counselor for sexual assault years ago.
So, seeing it grow and seeing it build,
it it it's great. It just feels good
knowing that women that run into
situations of sexual assault or not
having a home. It's great to know where
they can go.
>> Thank you. And I I think that's always
been our goal. When they built the
building, it was supposed to be, you
know, as nice
for the people that were coming in to
use it as it was for someone that was
wealthy that lived in the city. And what
we've really tried to do is take that
same level of care and and bring it to
the new and restore the structure. So,
it's doing the same thing regardless.
So,
appreciate you hearing that.
>> Thank you. I'll make a motion that we
move resolution 67
to full counsel on the 14th.
>> Second.
>> All those in favor?
>> I.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
Um, the last item on our agenda this
evening is council bill number 10,
2025, amending the zoning ordinance to
address data centers.
Good evening all.
>> Hello. Good evening.
>> Hi.
>> Connections. Yeah.
[Applause]
>> Dractor Del, have you connected using
that before?
>> I don't think so.
>> Okay, David's going to help you.
>> Okay.
>> With a quick little install.
Don't forget to hit your button there.
You're going to spread
Oh no.
Uh, good evening everybody. Uh, sorry
for the delay. I was looking for my
speaker notes, but we're going to go
with plan B and use the hard copy
instead.
Um,
okay. Um,
well, uh, thank you for the opportunity,
uh, to speak on this topic tonight. I
know there's been a lot of interest in,
uh, data centers overall, um, and
particularly, uh, subject of zoning. Um,
uh, first, uh, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I think all of you know me. I'm
Chris Del. I'm the director of community
planning and economic development. Uh
but wanted to introduce myself again um
uh for uh public in the room as well. Uh
also wanted to turn it over just for a
moment so that uh Betsy can introduce
herself as well.
>> Good evening. I'm Betsy Logan. I'm the
planning bureau chief for the city.
>> Okay. Um, I think I'm going to do most
of the talking, but um, Betsy is the
technical expert here in uh, a number of
the these areas, so she may assist with
some parts of the presentation and
answer uh, questions as well. Um, okay.
Uh, should we jump in?
>> Absolutely.
>> Good. Okay. Um, just wanted to start
with with where we've been. Uh on August
26th, city council directed staff um a
and the solicitor's office to develop a
zoning ordinance to specifically address
data centers in the city of Lancaster.
Um our chief planner, Betsy, who you
just met, and I have been working on the
draft ordinance since that time in
August uh in concert with our city
solicitor and also we have outside land
use council uh that we use for important
matters such as these. Um during that
time we've researched best practices.
We've spoken to experts. We've connected
with other mun municipalities and
generally attempted to build our
knowledge about data centers both their
challenges and their opportunities. Uh
please note this is a first draft of the
ordinance uh which will undergo
additional rounds of review and
feedback.
So, normally I end a presentation uh
with process. I don't usually start with
process, but I think in this case it's
really important. So, uh we're we're
clear about where we're headed. Um
formulating zoning code was designed to
be deliberative. In other words, it is a
slow process by nature. Um uh I think
the state and the local legislators
contemplated that this is intended to be
a slow uh slow process so that it's well
thought through before we make changes
to our zoning code. Um typically this
type of work uh the research and the
development of this kind of ordinance
takes in in the realm of 3 to four
months. Uh staff have expedited our work
at the request of council and most
importantly this is an important
community issue that has a sense of
urgency here. Um
on this slide I I wanted to talk about
the zoning process in in general. Uh
here on the left, whether uh this is a a
a data center consideration or any kind
of change to the zoning ordinance. Uh
there are steps that we must go through
as staff and uh as a city government. Uh
the first is essentially the
introduction of the zoning ordinance. Uh
the zoning amendment. Uh that's what's
happening here tonight. This is the
first presentment to to the city council
committee. Uh in addition to that, uh
there is a a review and comment or
recommendation by the city planning
commission and by the county planning
commission. There's also a public
hearing that is required by law.
Typically, that happens uh before city
council. That's how we have done done
this in the past. Uh and then because
it's an ordinance and not a resolution,
it requires at least it requires the two
readings before council and ultimately
uh vote and adoption if that's what you
uh so choose.
Um moving on to how that applies to uh
this particular zoning ordinance for the
data centers. Um there are a couple
dates that we know for sure right now.
Uh the first is tonight, October 6th. Uh
the second date is we have uh told our
city planning commission that after
tonight we will be sharing the ordinance
uh draft with them and that they will
have an opportunity to discuss this
ordinance uh draft ordinance on October
15th as well. There is uh a mandatory
45day review process with the county uh
staff and county planning commission. We
can come back and talk about that later
if it's valuable, but I just wanted to
note that here. Ultimately, uh we also
have to have the hearing and uh the two
readings before council that I
mentioned. These dates have not been set
in stone yet, but we have considered
that they would occur uh probably in the
end of October or during during the
month of December.
For the most part tonight, we're going
to talk about data centers in general
and how this zoning ordinance would
impact data centers throughout the city.
However, uh we we all know that two data
centers have been proposed in the city
at this time. One is on Greenfield Road
and one is on Harrisburg Pike. Uh I
think it's important to talk about the
zoning map uh and maybe to a certain
extent the comprehensive plan future
land use map as well.
the um the location or the data center
that has been proposed at the Greenfield
Road location is in the suburban
manufacturing zoning district. The uh
map on the left, you can see it's in the
top uh right corner in the uh blue
color. And then uh the Harrisburg Pike
location is in that lavender color. It's
uh in the central manufacturing zoning
district and it's sort of in the top
left uh fairly close to to Long's Park.
So, um one of the things I just wanted
to say in general here, I think there
may be more questions about this, but uh
it is not lawful for us as a
municipality to exclude any particular
land use in the city, including data
centers. our comp plan uh and our zone
zoning ordinance determines where
specific uses are best suited. So, um I
know there has been a lot of
consternation about the zoning
determination uh related to the
Greenfield Road site, for example. Um I
know there's some there's some granular
issues there at at play, but just wanted
to start with the suburban manufacturing
zoning district itself. I I want to read
you the definition from that particular
uh zoning district in our zoning code.
Okay. So again, this is suburban
manufacturing. Uh they're not a a lot of
uh this district does not cover a lot of
land in the city. Um but this is where
the 216 Greenfield Road uh is located.
The suburban manufacturing district is
intended to accommodate the most intense
industrial uses which have greater land
area requirements and need for close
proximity to regional transportation
networks including railway and limited
access highways.
There's more there uh related to other
commercial and retail uses but I think
that that applies most to what we're
talking about here uh in the case of a
data center.
[Music]
Okay,
before we jump into the uh content of
the ordinance, I I think um you all have
a copy of the draft ordinance in front
of you and I believe it's been shared
with uh the the audience as well and
we'll get into some of the components of
that ordinance shortly. Uh I would like
to acknowledge uh the work that
community stakeholders have already done
here. Uh for example uh we have read and
incorporated um ideas from uh example
ordinances that were provided to us. Um
some time ago Mr. Kenneth Weekes who's
one of our uh city planning
commissioners uh provided us some
information uh an example. Uh we also
took a look at the document that Mr. uh
uh Arolio provided to city at the last
city council meeting as well. Um and
that along with a lot of resource other
resources that we've looked at have gone
into this process.
Um I'm going to take this uh the
ordinance a piece at a time. We're not
going to have time to go through every
uh every word or every section, but I do
want to highlight uh parts of it because
I think it will be helpful for the
dialogue.
First of all, uh a as with any
ordinance, we start with the whereas
clauses. The intent here is to frame the
purpose and need of uh this change to
our code. Section uh one is the
definition of the data center. And this
part is important. So we'll
uh thank you. I got it.
So per the draft ordinance, a data
center is a facility whose primary
purpose is the centralized storage,
processing, management or dissemination
of digital data, information or
applications. This includes but is not
limited to server farms, cloud computing
hubs, collocation centers and telecom uh
sorry telecommunication switching hubs.
Data centers typically house large-scale
computer systems and supporting
infrastructure such as backup
generators, cooling systems, and
uninterruptible power supplies. A data
center generally includes environmental
controls such as air conditioning and
fire suppression, redundant/backup
power supplies, redundant data
communications connections, and high
security.
There's a lot there.
Uh so there's a lot there's a lot to
consider. Uh and I wanted to read the
definition because it's important as we
consider uh how we're dealing with these
different parts of what a a data center
actually is.
Uh in addition to that, the next part of
the ordinance is related to the table of
permitted uses. You can see here uh this
is an excerpt from the manufacturing and
industrial portion of the of the table
that governs the acceptable uses here.
Essentially what this is saying is that
data centers would be uh prohibited or
not allowed in any of the zoning
districts throughout the city with the
exception of suburban manufacturing and
central manufacturing. Now the in this
proposal
uh that use data centers would not be
allowed by right. They would be allowed
by special exception and that applies to
the content really of the rest of the
ordinance here. Uh data centers would
only be granted that special exception
by the zoning hearing board uh through
the meeting of those of the standards
that are outlined here are detailed here
in the zoning ordinance.
Uh I I know this is very dense so I'm
going to take a pause there. Uh that was
really the first uh introduction framing
of the data of the data center ordinance
before we start to get into more of the
details related to uh the standards. Uh
do count council members have any
questions at this time?
I do. Okay.
So, my question is related to the noise.
Is there like I know that they have
decibb levels. Um, and I'm not sure the
acoustic. I'm thinking that you would
have like 85 55 to 85 dBs. Is that
something that would be outside or is it
around 95 or 96? Do you have what levels
there'll be? because I'm sure that
those that live close by, especially the
one on um Hyrisburg Pike especially, um
that they have mentioned the fact that
they want to know how loud that is going
to be.
>> Yeah, Council Diaz, thank you uh for the
question. And if you don't mind, I'm
going to circle back to that very
briefly. Um before I jump into the noise
category, I I just wanted to call your
attention to uh the slide that is up
now. Uh that is section three of the
ordinance and it uh includes all of
these different topic areas. The first
topic area is actually noise and we can
uh take some time to speak about that. I
just wanted to show that um this this
really represented the uh the rest of of
the ordinance content here. Council
Craig, go ahead.
>> Um, Director Delves, um,
first things first, um, at your
convenience, if you could please forward
the slide deck to council as we don't
have access to our screens this evening.
Um,
we don't we haven't we don't um um, but
uh, second uh, the definition of of data
center. Can you talk about how you
arrived at that definition? Was it
derived from other sources? Is it a a
common definition? How did we arrive at
that?
>> Yeah, it it is a fairly common
definition. Um we've been working with
Lancaster County Planning Commission on
getting um ordinances that have been
approved or in the process of being
approved within the county. And so we
utilize that ordinance as well as like
research that's been done um mostly in
Virginia because they have so many and
they've really are kind of in their
second or third round of updates to
their ordinances to making sure they're
addressing everything.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> Any any further questions for
council?
>> I'm sorry, Council President. I just
want to make sure I understood your
request. Were you were you saying that
you would like me to send it later on or
would you like me to forward it now?
>> If if perhaps uh Betsy if you have
access to it or I see okay Rebecca has
it that would be great. That way we
could have it in real time. So
>> Okay,
>> perfect.
>> Great.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. Shall I keep rolling?
>> Keep going.
>> Okay. Thank you.
As I showed in that last table, there
are a lot of sections. Uh we're not
going to go through each of those
sections tonight, but I did want to call
out um a handful of those sections that
we have heard u a lot of concern from
from the public directly both council
meetings and and through other avenues
as well. Uh the first topic is is noise.
Uh so thank thank you again councelor
Diaz. um what what we're trying to do
here in the ordinance there there's
actually two parts. One requires a noise
mitigation plan that's submitted with
the zoning application. So that's
looking at a holistic approach to
minimizing or mitigating noise. Uh in
part two, it also says there shall be no
noise disturbance as that term is
defined in the city uh city's noise
control ordinance. So what we're trying
to do here is link it to uh an ordinance
that already exists. Uh from our
standpoint, we do think that the noise
ordinance that we have in place is a
strong ordinance. If you uh it is not
your question was about decibel level.
That is one way that we could go as
staff as a council. Uh what we have
propos proposed so far is to really um
focus on the the impact of the residents
not the measurement. And so noise
disturbance as uh as defined in the
noise ordinance is uh any sound
specified in another part of the
ordinance or any sound which a endangers
or injures the safety or health of
humans or animals, b annoys or disturbs
a reasonable person of normal
sensitivities or c endangers or injures
personal or real property.
So that's how we've proposed to handle
it so far. As I said, there are
different different ways to approach
this and uh the ordinance will continue
to evolve here through the process.
Going uh to the next
topic here is air quality that is
section uh 3B.
We have two parts here to the air qual
quality section. Part one states that
backup power equipment shall minimize
air pollutant emissions and meet or
exceed applicable state and federal laws
regulating emissions in the case that
backup generators are used. EPA tier 4
emission standards or equivalent must be
achieved. Also section B2,
annual testing shall be performed and
reports shall be provided to the city
and other relevant state and federal
agencies to ensure that data center
equipment is performing as designed and
emissions from the data center do not
exceed allowable limits. Uh one of the
things to note here is that air quality
is governed by a state uh process. It's
a air quality permit that is managed by
the department of environmental
protection. We can come back to that
later in the presentation.
The third item here on the slide is
section C, energy use.
And again, section C has two parts. Uh
part one, data centers shall make good
faith efforts to maximize use of
renewable andor clean energy for all
electrical and cooling needs either
through on-site generation or verifiable
power purchase agreements. Part two, uh,
C2, an emergency management plan shall
be submitted, uh, I'm sorry, an energy
management plan shall be submitted with
the zoning application detail detailing
at a minimum annual electricity demand,
what supply sources will be utilized,
energy storage capacity and efforts made
to maximize use of renewable renewable
or clean energy. Uh this is another area
that um we actually have discussed this
one at length with our solicitor and uh
this is a difficult area to regulate
through zoning law through zoning
ordinance. I think there's more more to
talk about here um in terms of how we
have discussed this issue with uh the
developer Carissa and we'll again come
back to that later.
Uh the last
topic that I elected to call out here in
the slide is section D water
utilization. And uh D part one states,
"A water utilization report shall be
submitted with the zoning application
detailing at a minimum the total daily
intake volume and sources of that water,
discharge volumes and destinations,
cooling system type and efficiency and
shall demonstrate compliance with the
city's storm water ordinances and
regulations.
One of the things uh that is also
important to note here is that this
water use is not governed by uh by
zoning alone. It is uh governed by a
number of other city approvals. And as
you may have seen in a recent uh
Lancaster newspaper article, there are
decisions that are made by the uh
Suscoana River Basin Commission related
to how much water can be used for a
particular project.
One of the things that um we've talked
about here is making sure that we're not
seeing water use
um grow beyond a certain level. And
again, we'll come back to that.
There are uh several other sections in
the zoning ordinance that are more
typical for a zoning ordinance. uh that
we see throughout uh other kinds of uses
not data centers alone. Most of these
are related to physical design issues.
So they're examples uh related to
parking setbacks, uh yard buffers,
screening, all these are very important
issues but perhaps a little more
straightforward because uh zoning is
used to regulate these items. If you if
you have questions about any of these
particular topics, we can come back to
them. And then last but not least, uh we
have a couple sections at the end of the
ordinance that are uh not necessarily
physical design, but there are other
priorities that we thought were
important to include in the zoning
ordinance. One uh is a requirement for
an emergency management plan. That is
section M. And then uh lastly section N
is related to community engagement and
that states that the developer of the
data center uh shall hold a public
informationational meeting prior to any
zoning hearing board or planning
commission review. As you know and as
part of this process you see there are a
lot of opportunities for uh public to
engage through a formal board or
commission or city council. Uh this is
an additional uh requirement in addition
to th those processes.
[Applause]
Okay. Um, turning our attention from the
zoning amendment for a moment. Uh, we
are not ready to discuss the details of
a community benefits agreement with, uh,
the developer, Carissa, tonight. Uh but
it is important to note that work is
happening in tandem on the zoning
amendment and the community benefits
agreement. There's a lot of crossover
among these topics and we've been trying
to work uh carefully and thoughtfully
about how these things interact.
Um I believe that the administration uh
and Mayor Sarra will have some
additional updates about the community
benefits agreement later in the month.
Uh again, not quite ready to talk about
that and uh I also don't want to muddy
the waters and confuse things because
we're really here to focus on the zoning
amendment tonight.
Um
coming back to these four topics, noise,
air quality, energy, and water. Um we
are working to ensure that we understand
and minimize noise disturbance.
Carissa has already told us that they're
designing toward ensuring that data
centers do not increase ambient noise
levels. Of course, this is going to take
work to make sure that this is
documented and memorialized, but that is
what we are hearing so far. Uh, in
addition, the data center facilities uh
have been designed to meet all
requirements of a minor air quality
permit as determined by the Pennsylvania
Department of Environmental Protection.
The city is engaged uh in that process
with D and we're interacting with them
directly. We've been asking questions.
We've been following up on a number of
different things related to the design
and operation of the backup generators.
That again is regulated entirely by the
state D.
Although the city does uh does play a
role in uh
um serving as a party and providing our
comments to D
with respect to energy. um did want to
share that there there are a variety of
electric infrastructure investments that
will be required as part of the data
centers that have been proposed.
Uh at at this point uh Chrissa has uh
been in um conversation and negotiation
with PPL uh and will be establishing
which of those facilities will be uh
which will be paid for by Carissa.
Essentially uh
the the intent there is that Carissa
will be covering the costs of any uh
electrical power infrastructure that is
directly serving uh their data centers
and in addition to that there are
potential benefits to strengthening the
local power grid as well.
Finally, with respect to uh the water
utilization, uh as as I mentioned
before, there was a recent article about
the sustain uh Suscoana um river basin
commission and Kursa reported to them
and they have reported to us city
administration uh that they will be
remaining under 20,000 gallons per day
per data center campus. So, there's a
campus proposed at Greenfield Road again
and a campus proposed at Harrisburg
Pike. Each of those we've been told will
remain under 20,000 uh gallons. Again,
this is all this is all based upon uh
dialogue and uh conversation.
What has to come next is related to
documentation and the community benefits
agreement. There are other topics and
issues that would come in the CBA, but
uh wanted to connect these topics
from the zoning amendment to the CBA.
Okay, I'm gonna I'm going to pause there
again uh and see if there are additional
questions. I do want I do want to bring
us back to to the process and again
recognize that uh happy to answer any
questions we have tonight, but it is
very possible that the zoning uh
amendment, the zoning ordinance
amendment may evolve through these other
steps in the process as well.
Great. Um, Council President,
>> thank you. Um, Dr. Dels, uh, under
specifically water utilization and
perhaps this is similar to energy use
and and you know and the noise uh the
way we've uh the approach we're taking
with this.
>> Yes.
>> Um, is it possible to put an actual
limitation on water usage in a zoning
ordinance itself? Is that a thing?
>> No. No, it's not a thing, Council
President. Unfortunately, because um we
that would be regulating businesses
ostensibly because the zoning ordinance
has to be agnostic
in terms of one category of uses cannot
conflict with another category of uses.
And so we are we are procluded from
putting in a specific limitation related
to water. But as director delves
mentioned there are other um policies
related to water utilization. And then
there is also the Saskcoana River Basin
Commission. And then um you know I think
just to put a pin a finer point on what
director delves is saying is that um
there are communic there are
conversations that are happening related
to the community community benefits
agreement that will go beyond the zoning
ordinance.
>> Sure.
>> And so I'll I'll be prepared to talk
about those later and be able to con to
um contrast the zoning text amendment
with the community benefits agreement.
that for the purposes of a zoning text
amendment we have to be we have to tread
very carefully because we cannot
preclude any use uh in the city and we
also cannot put a burden on one
particular use over another use.
So, for example, requiring the data
center uh to not use more than 20,000
gallons of water or to require them to
use um a particular source of energy. Uh
those are two examples. And I will just
say that we um
zoning has strengths and limitations.
I I will also add we've had a lot of
very uh healthy discussions and
wrestling matches with uh our with our
solicitor uh and with our outside land
use council trying to ask all of these
questions and understanding what uh
zoning ordinance will ultimately be the
most effective and and also defensible
that will that will hold up.
>> Understood. Thank you,
>> Councelor Med. Uh thank you councelor
Craig and thank you Director Delves and
city staff uh for your thoroughess in uh
this zoning amendment. Uh my question is
um if approved will this retroactively
apply to the two data centers that are
currently being proposed.
I this is is the question that everyone
has been interested in and unfortunately
I don't have a satisfactory answer right
now because the the sincere answer is
that the the city does not yet have a
definitive legal position on whether
this zoning amendment would apply to um
these two sites. Uh there are a number
of moving parts that are happening right
now and uh reasonable attorneys could
disagree about uh when this would apply.
So the the official position right now
is that we are not sure yet. And so it
it's important that we're doing as good
a job as possible on uh the zoning
amendment and that we're continuing to
have uh good dialogue with uh Chrissa uh
who who so far has negotiated in in good
faith and has been um uh I I have found
them so far to be a sincere uh partner
in those conversations.
>> Thank you. And my final question, what
you just mentioned is um the the
textment states that data centers shall
make good faith efforts to maximize use
of renewable andor clean energy. Um
other than the verifiable power purchase
agreements, what other metrics do we
have to show that they're acting in good
faith?
[Applause]
Yeah, I I appreciate the question and uh
this is where we are trying to stretch
into some territory to ensure that uh a
developer this developer or any future
developer of a data center uh that they
are required to be intentional and
thoughtful and um put together an energy
management plan that tries to achieve
these goals. uh it would be very
difficult for us to hold a developer to
say a specific percentage of uh
renewable uh energy. That's one thing
that we've talked about as staff
internally for example. Um
>> one of the things that we've also talked
about as a goal is trying to ensure that
uh there is limited to no fossil fuel
use.
Many of these data centers because of
the huge energy draw that they require
are uh looking to use nuclear power and
um there are different opinions about
nuclear power. It is considered uh a
cleaner source of fuel. Obviously it
does come with other other challenges.
Uh but I do think that any data most
data centers in the country now are um
seeking to use nuclear power at least as
some part of their power portfolio
>> and also renewable as we've seen the $3
billion purchase of um hydro power by
Google on the Suscoana River over the
next 20 years. So that I think that
there's a combination of factors um in
uh that are at play here in terms of the
the power utilization or the power
source uh and also pushing up against
the limits of what we can accomplish in
a zoning text amendment.
>> Thank you. And I appreciate the work
being done by your department and by
city staff. And I would just hope that
we uh continue to think about ways to
protect city residents against vague
goodfaith effort definitions. Yep. I we
we agree and uh that that is there to
require that there's planning and
there's thinking. Um but we are
continuing to push on the issue of
renewable as as the mayor mentioned. I I
think that's very important.
>> Are there any further questions from
council as a whole?
>> Councelor Hirs.
>> Uh thank you, Director DS. Um
kind of a question, kind of a comment.
Um, and it might come across as odd. Um,
but I know for me in as far as
evaluating, you know, what the zoning
can do and and what the city can do and
regulate. Um, and as far as what some of
my concerns are, I would say noise is
definitely one that I have. Um, and I
would just hope um that the city would
consider evaluating that at night. and
um and during the day because I know
there's been talk about other ambient
sound kind of um that it being neutral
with that sound, but um just making sure
that we're evaluating that at all times
of the day because these are operating
um you know 24/7.
>> Yes,
>> you do. Councelor Diaz,
>> in relations to the noise again, has
anybody from the administration gone to
another data center to hear or to see
what the frequencies or what, you know,
the decimals, what what the acoustics
are like. I'm just curious if that's if
that was a possibility.
>> I can take that, Chris. Director Delves.
Um what I would say, councelor Diaz, is
that we have um hired outside expertise
that has worked um both representing um
communities concerned about noise from
data centers as well as data center
developers themselves who have to meet u
certain standards related to noise. Uh
to address the the design of these
facilities um to ensure that um that uh
noise is not a factor. And so while um
city staff have not taken the time to to
drive or go to another site, we have
actually hired expertise um in this
regard to assist us in making sure that
um their um
uh noise analysis is being independently
reviewed by a third party and um
reported back um to the administration.
And um and I I believe that that process
is uh happening uh this week and next
week for uh both of the for for the
phase one and phase two that are
contemplated at at Greenfield. So this
is to say that um we are not relying on
our expertise. We're relying on the
expertise of folks with um a lot more
experience in uh in in approaching these
projects in a way that is sensitive to
um the amount of noise that can be uh
generated um by their use.
>> Okay. So
>> Okay. Thank you. Um, I'll take questions
and comments from the public.
[Music]
>> We can see that this document title
of residence.
>> My name is Matthew Barton. I'm on the
800 block of North Prince.
>> Thank you.
We can see this this document tacitly
acknowledges the numerous potential
downsides of this facility to the
community. Energy and water use and
pollution chief among them I'll
acknowledge the glaring lack of detail
around the proposed limits of this
facility at this time. What I'm failing
to see is the benefit to the city at
large or any individual residents of
Lancaster. This kind of facility creates
no meaningful number of community jobs,
provides no necessary or desired local
service. Any argued tax benefits to the
community would ignore the long-standing
tradition in this country of corporate
entities evading their responsible tax
burdens to the local community. And even
ignoring that pale in comparison to the
litany of medical issues that these
facilities have already proven to lead
to in the short term. And that doesn't
even account the currently unproven
long-term environmental and health
impacts.
There's no amount of financial benefit
offered by these data centers that could
conceivably offset the corresponding
detriment to public health and welfare.
It's very easy to find stories about
communities that have suffered because
of these data centers, but I've yet to
see a single story of a community glad
to have them. I think we should sit and
think on that. Thank you,
>> Mr. Dastra.
How you doing?
>> Wonderful.
>> Tony Dash at 700 block of New Holland
Avenue. I will do my best to keep this
one positive uh because I'm very glad to
see this ordinance, Director Del. It is
way more robust than I honestly had been
anticipating. So, I appreciate the
reviews you've done of all the
documentation you've been provided by
the public. Um I do have some notes and
I also want to thank you for your
calling out of the good faith. That was
one of the things I underlined as soon
as I read this. Um, so moving on from
the good faith, that will definitely
come up later in other agenda items, but
uh, I want to encourage the council to
change it from special exception to
conditional use, especially in light of
not having an updated zoning amendment
right now. This is working in between
where we need to get with our
comprehensive plan uh, and what where
we're at right now. So I think the most
acceptable thing for the public would to
be having conditional uses because as
these data centers move through our
community, it holds this body directly
accountable to what products are
approved. Um in addition to that, I
believe under electronic waste, uh Mr.
Darolio has persuaded me that we need to
have a bond to guarantee that those
plans get enacted and that should be
outlined explicitly in those um
electronic waste plans with a bond. Um
as far as water utilization goes, I do
believe there's a way for us to draft
agnostic legislation because industrial
use of water, not just for data centers
but other facilities, is something that
is a very real impact for our community.
potable water where it's available
especially in a community a community
like ours that is dependent on rainfall
to dilute the um what are we calling
them pas in our water it's critical that
we save every drop of potable water we
have so they shouldn't be going to just
cooling uses if something's not
producing a consumable product by humans
animals or otherwise agricultural use I
think we need to eliminate that
um yeah I mean honestly this is a nice
big packet it. I'm very uh happy to see
the direction we're heading in as far as
the legislation goes. Obviously, we as
as a community have more work to do when
it comes to these existing data centers.
I'm looking forward to seeing uh the
review by planning commission, which for
the record I'm on. Um
cuz we are a little bit behind on where
we need to be with this. Uh the fact
that we are in this place, we should
have never gotten to this place. Um,
so those are the changes I would
recommend making to uh this ordinance. I
will obviously say those things at
planning commission as well. I
appreciate the public for continuing in
this fight uh to protect our honestly
not just our well-being but our
ecosystem for uh generations to come and
thank you. Please move this forward so
we can get something in place.
>> Thank you Mr. Dastra.
Um,
there you go.
You knew I'd be up here. Frank Archolio,
uh, Old Trinity Place. Uh, yeah. So, uh,
I have to say that this is a lot better
than I expected. Um, and I recognize a
lot of the language in here, like some
of the definitions and and things like
that that look very similar to uh to
what I uh handed out at the last city
council meeting. Uh there are there are
some things that are missing. Um I think
uh things about grid costs. uh energy
energy management plan has been uh the
fact that it is that that uh PPL will
not give information about any energy
agreements that it has with customers. I
think we need we would definitely need
to require that the uh the applicants
provide their uh energy use plan. Um I
think there's uh some stuff that is
missing here. There's not a
decommissioning plan. There's a lot of
uh lot of talk in uh uh in the financial
circles that we are in a large data
center bubble and that that bubble could
burst at any time. uh and uh and so it
is possible that at the first turnaround
when the first set of uh of chips become
obsolete that all of a sudden that data
center completely refurbished with new
chips will not be able to compete and
will be decommissioned. Um I would hate
to see them just walking away and
throwing the keys on the roof. We need a
decommissioning plan and as Mr. Dastra
said for all of these plans, the energy
management plan, the water utilization
plan, the electronic waste plan, the
heat mitigation plan, all of these
things should be accompanied by a
performance bond so that if they don't
meet the terms that they uh that they
have uh that they have said that uh
there are not only legal remedies but
also financial penalties uh that we can
that we can extract. Um, you know, I I I
guess probably the longest term thing is
the energy problem. Um, and and you know
what? I think familiarizing yourself
with the with data centers in order to
draft this ordinance was a great thing.
I just believe that it should have been
done way before the first set was ever
uh agreed to by the city and that um and
that I still believe that my appeal will
be successful because if you look at the
definitions and you look at uh the the
the differences between warehouses and
what's been defined here, you will see
that they are not the same. There's no
way to confuse them and there never
should have been anything at all
approving those things without this kind
of uh work ahead of time and this kind
of process that takes it through uh both
a uh multi-step
uh official process as well as a public
comment process. So uh I think this is a
great first step. Um, I think I think we
can improve on it and um and good luck.
I hope we can Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Hello, my name is Jacob Datisman, uh,
recent resident over on King and Lime
Street. I just have a couple questions.
Um,
I would like to see, uh, how the zoning
rules would be regulated. Um, and
additionally, uh, what kind of
consequences there will be for these
corporations who are establishing these
centers in our community. Uh, right now,
uh, I haven't been to any of the earlier
meetings, but right now I'm looking at a
few pages with a lot of vague wording,
no metrics, and no accountability. Uh,
and that really concerns me. I moved all
the way across the country with my wife.
We want to start a new life here, and we
don't want to see it destroyed for a few
dozen jobs. Um, so if we could uh revise
it a little bit and get some hard
numbers, get some facts, get some
figures from the other data centers,
like the other gentleman said, they're
affecting other cities and states across
America with these giant data centers,
the health, the environment. Uh, that
would be greatly appreciated and I'm
very happy to be before you and allowed
to give public comment and we would love
to see that continue. Um, thank you.
>> Thank you.
I like this new like setup from back
there. But uh my name is Taylor
Enterline. I'm a community organizer
with Lancaster Stands Up. I'm from the
Manheim Burough.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> Oh god. Um my name is Taylor Interline.
I'm a community organizer with Lancaster
Stands Up. I'm part of Mannheim Burough,
though. I just wanted to really thank
council and y'all who time for taking
the time to write this um ordinance.
It's very important. My favorite part is
in terms of the need for community
input, especially for the community
taxing and cost that will be on our
folks here. Um, and wanting to point out
of the fact that one individual went
behind the backs of many people to sell
out our community for big tech and now
we have to go through all this to make
sure that amendments are made. Um, so my
hope is that u once we get the answers
if this would be retroactive and and
around the community uh benefits
agreement hoping that there's an open
forum for our folks to actually have
input on that before any decisions are
made are really important. Thank you for
your time.
>> Thank you.
[Applause]
>> All right. Um Taylor Raymond, 500 block
of St. Joseph Street. Um I agree with
everyone who's spoken previously. They
are a lot more eloquent and smarter than
me in regards to the data center. Um I
have a couple of questions. Um so if a
if a plan is approved and the
uh a data center is developed
and then what they submitted
uh doesn't or what they do doesn't live
up to what they submitted. It doesn't
meet the requirements. What consequences
do they suffer under this current uh
zoning ordinance or under the proposed
one? Um, and then, uh, additionally
about the community benefits agreement.
Um, so I looked up just a basic
definition of what that was just to make
sure I knew what I was talking about.
Um, and it says that it is a contract
signed by community groups and a real
estate developer. Um, so I wanted to
know what community groups are involved
in that. Um, because I don't I don't
know of any and I would love to know if
there are any um that are being
included.
Thank you.
>> Um,
>> can I get some answers on those?
>> Um, I we're not going to do um question
and answer right at this moment. I will
after meeting or you can submit your
question to the clerk and we'll get it
answered.
>> Councilor Craig.
>> Sure. Go ahead. I would just endeavor to
try to answer that. Uh Dr. Delves, you
said that we're very early in that
process for community benefit. So I
don't know that we have that
just yet that we're at that point, but
it's well taken. So thank you. Um and
the first question, I can't remember it
at this point, but I wanted to say
something about it and now I can't
remember.
>> Um it was the what consequences would
they suffer if they plan?
>> Thank you. I share that question. So Dr.
Del, if you could just speak generally
about how zoning ordinances are
enforced, that may be helpful in the
context of this question. Thank you.
>> Sure. Very quickly on the community
benefits agreement, we're planning to
speak about that uh later in the month.
So, I do think it'd be premature to talk
about that now. I do appreciate the
question. Um,
>> I I'll let uh Betsy answer the question
about uh the zoning enforcement just in
general. Yeah, just in general because
this is uncharted territory, but
>> Yes, indeed. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Um, so zoning enforcement is already
written in the zoning ordinance. It's a
set procedure. The zoning officer, if
there is an enforcement issue, um, a
complaint or violation, he would
investigate that complaint and he would
file a notice of violation. Um, that
would go through the process that can be
appealed to the zoning hearing board.
Um, the notice of violation can or at
um, who can make changes to any
approvals they have. they can uphold it,
they can deny it. Um, but it would go
through the zoning hearing board.
>> So, the same process that any zoning
violations would
>> generally, yes, they can. If they don't
address the the concern or the issue
after a notice of violation is sent in
um, and no actions been taken, we can
file with the district magistrate on
those. Um,
>> I would foresee that probably not
happening with this. It doesn't happen
frequently, but it is recourse that it's
available to us. Okay. Thank you.
>> Okay.
>> Upon seeing no one else up at the mic.
>> Hello, my name is Sophia Pengurn. I'm
from the 200s block of uh King Street.
And I just want to 100% clarify just to
make sure that I understood this
correctly that even if this zoning uh
thing is passed, it doesn't necessarily
apply to the two warehouses that are
currently already uh being proposed and
built. Correct.
>> Uh right. So what what I was hoping we
could do uh tonight uh and in the
process, we we have to think about this
zoning amendment as applying to the
entire city. I do understand uh that
there's a key question related to uh
there's the east campus proposed at
Greenfield Road and the west campus uh
proposed at Harrisburg Pike. And as I
said earlier, the city does not have a
legal position at this point about
whether it would apply to uh to either
of those sites because of the progress
that the Greenfield Road site has made
through the building permit process. For
example, um on phase one, uh
the developer is more legally safe with
the fact that they've proceeded with
with that work if you understand me. But
it's it it is not a black and white
answer.
>> Okay. Okay. So that so that's why I'm
saying that at there has been no
determination yet for certain about
whether this zoning amendment would
apply to those two sites.
>> Okay. So this all of this has been
complete hypotheticals and there's just
absolutely no guarantee that there will
be any kind of precautions for noise,
for environmental safety, for
electricity, for responsibility in any
kind of way. like there is absolutely no
recourse or rules that these warehouses
have to follow um if this does not apply
to them in the future.
>> That's not how the city's approaching
it. No.
>> Okay.
Thank you.
>> Is anybody else going to sneak up to the
mic?
Okay. Thank you. Upon seeing no one else
at the mic, I'm going to make Oh, first
of all, let me make a clarification
because I think in the very beginning
that I referred to this as council bill
5 and it's council bill 10.
Okay. And then now I would like to make
a motion to move council bill 10 to full
counsel on the
>> 14th.
>> Okay. All those in favor?
>> Well, second.
>> Second. Thank you. And then all those in
favor?
>> I I thank you. Um, Council President,
that concludes community planning for
this evening.
>> Thank you very much, Director Del, and
and your team. Thank you very much for
that. Uh, we look forward to continued
conversation about it.
>> We'll now move to the public safety
committee, Council Diaz.
>> Thank you, uh, President. Um public uh
safety committee has administration bill
number 082025 authorizing automated red
light enforcement.
This ordinance um authorizes the city of
Lancaster to implement and enforce
automated red light camera in designated
intersections in accordance to
Pennsylvania law. And I will let our
wonderful representative here to uh
discuss that.
Thank you, Councelor Diaz. Um Cindy
McCormack. I'm from the Department of
Public Works. Um we've been working
closely with the the police department
on the automated red light running um uh
legislate or in um program and I'll be
here to present a little bit more
information about it.
So, as you mentioned, this is a request
to uh for an ordinance authorizing the
enforcement of red light running cameras
through an automated system. The system
would also be approved by PENDOT. Um, so
just for people that aren't familiar
with automated red light running
cameras, they're cameras that are
located at traffic signals and they
record red light running uh violations.
Police then review these um photos to
confirm violations and then they al they
approve the citations that are issued
and then tickets are mailed to the
registered um uh vehicle owners as part
of the program.
So why are we looking at automated red
light running enforcement? Um as you're
all aware, we're very heavily invested
in traffic safety throughout the city.
Our vision zero plan has a focus on
eliminating uh fatal and serious injury
crashes. So this is a another tool for
us to uh use in um deterring
uh speeding and other behaviors that
lead to crashes. Um just to give a
little bit more background, in 2025
there were 25 seriously injured or
killed people in the city of Lancaster.
We have over 700 crashes per year.
approximately half of those involve some
form of injury. Um and we have 35 to 40
crashes generally during the year that
involve pedestrians. So, um we're
looking to implement as many tools as we
can to um improve safety in the city.
Um with the accreditation of the police
department recently that allowed us to
move forward with this program.
Um, and the goals of the program are to
reduce the red light running violations.
Um, a lot of studies have shown once
these cameras are implemented, the
actual number of violations um, go down
over time. So, that's obviously what
we're trying to curb that red light
running behavior. Um, it reduces angle
crashes. Um, angle crashes often result
in higher degrees of in injuries. So
studies have shown that um some red
light running cameras will reduce uh all
injury crashes by approximately 20% and
up to 30% for right angle uh crashes.
So this is uh has been proven to be
effective in reducing crashes.
It also has um been known to have a
spillover effect. So this ordinance is
requesting installation of cameras at
five intersections within the city. Um,
but once a program has been implemented,
often there is a a reduction in red
light running in general throughout the
area.
So, the locations in this ordinance um
are listed um on the second page of the
ordinance, but they include King Street
and Lime, King and Water, uh Columbia
Avenue and West End Avenue, Lime and
Walnut, and then Manor, Hershey, and
West End. And these locations were
selected based on the highest number of
crashes um contributed to red light
running. Um we also tried to disperse
them throughout the city. So not
focusing on any one particular area. And
then uh we've also had some initial
coordination with PENDOT who has to
approve uh the locations that we choose
as well.
So, just to provide a little bit more
information, um the program would
include and a lot of the details of the
program are listed out in the ordinance,
but uh the program does include, you
know, required education and signage
associated with the cameras and also
includes a 60-day initial period where
um violations are not issued. It's more
warnings. So, there's plenty of public
notice about the program. Um the tickets
will be civil offenses. They are not
considered criminal. They do not add
points to anyone's record. Um
the city will have to set up since it is
a civil um violation, the city will have
to set up an appeal process for those
civil violations. Um but that is part of
what we um plan to do. Um
and
uh the system will not generate any
revenue for the city. um fines are
collected and the city is uh is
reimbured for their expenses related to
the police time as well as the vendor is
reimbursed for those expenses. Any uh
additional revenue over that would go
back to the state. Um a lot of this
funding um that goes back to the state
is used for automated red light
enforcement grants which the city is
often a recipient of as well. So the
city's not um would not be able to make
any uh revenue related to this program.
Um and we're also required if if this
plan if this program is implemented we
would be required to do annual reports
to pendot noting the number of
violations and detailing out revenue and
uh expenses related to the program.
So, uh, if this is approved, the next
steps would be to make a formal request
to PNEDOT for and then because this has
to be approved by the Secretary of
Transportation,
um, and then we would issue an RFP for
vendors.
>> Okay. Is there any questions from the
committee?
>> Um, thank you so much, Mrs. McCormack,
for the presentation. Um,
my question is, will this also capture
someone that would illegally turn right
in a no turn on red situation?
>> Yes, we can set it up so that it will
collect those uh violations as well.
>> Very good. Um, and I just want to make a
comment uh in support of this because um
I witness it every day, people running
red lights. Um, it's incredibly
dangerous. Um, I had a dear friend who
was hit, um, severely injured both
physically and emotionally, mentally.
Um, and I'm just really glad to see the
city pursue this in their nest. Um,
because I think it's, uh, I think it's
long overdue.
>> Thank you.
>> Any other questions from council?
Yes. Thank you, councelor Diaz.
Miss McCormack, thank you so much. This
is is this is very exciting and I would
echo council Hirch's comments and
support. Um I also just want to put a
fine point on the fact that because this
will be the headline, right? Um this is
the city is trying to make money. Um so
to confirm, we cannot make any money off
of this program because after we are
reimbursed for our time and we pay for
the technology, it goes to the state of
Pennsylvania. Is that correct?
>> Absolutely correct.
>> Thank you so much.
And um I'll open up to um to any
comments because I'm sure that the
public might want to make a comment
about this.
Jessica Lopez Lancaster
president. I guess this is one um where
I'm not, you know, pro helping the
police. Um I do believe we have an
enormous amount of hit runs in this city
that do not get solved. So, um, yes,
where safety is concerned, we do need
new measures, but we shouldn't be
relying on
trapping our residents to make money.
Um, I get that our city needs to find
ways to pay for it, but it shouldn't be
coming from trapping our residents, no
matter what that looks like. if that is
paying attention to if they turned right
on red. Um, we pay out our
wazoos to live in Lancaster as it stands
right now with the way our cost of
living is and where I like I said, I do
believe we need to do something because
safety is prevalent. Um, I also know
somebody that was in a hit and run um at
the beginning of this year and
they suffered immensely. So yes, we do
need to do something, but I don't
believe that we should be searching for
ways to entrap people to fix our
financial issues.
I know, but that's was the statement
that was made about whether we were
going to make any money off of this. And
no, we're not where it needs to happen.
It shouldn't be about if we're going to
make money off of it. It should be about
if our residents are going to be safe or
not. To clarify, Miss Lopez, the reason
I asked that question was because I
wanted to make sure it was clear that we
didn't because that's not my wish
either.
>> Is that I'm like, nope. We we pay
>> I don't think we should do that either.
>> Like we pay out the wazoo in parking
tickets. We're paying out the wazoo in
housing costs. I just think that where
we do need safer solutions like
something on Manor and Filbert that
decreases the speed because I just
almost watched a kid get hit by a car
two days ago. Um, but we don't have a
light there. We do need different things
implemented. I just think it should be
fiscally better for our residents.
>> All right. Uh, hi, my name's uh, Nikolai
Gikis. I'm a resident on 300 West Lemon,
that block. Um there's there definitely
are studies that don't necessarily show
it improves safety. Um I was looking at
one right here before. Uh I didn't know
this was on the agenda. Uh and so I uh I
can provide that for anyone who wants
uh it essentially was a study in Houston
saying they stopped the red light
cameras and they said, "Well, we're not
totally sure whether or not it improved
safety or not." and slam on the brakes
when they were like, you know, just
about to uh like blow it. I'm saying
like much earlier creating, you know,
dangerous incidents. I've been in the
car in front or, you know, behind those
people who have been in those uh
situations. I don't necessarily believe
that this will improve safety. I think
it might just change the accidents that
we're seeing here in Lancaster. Um, I
would also just say that anecdotally
from well from where, you know, I grew
up, uh, very happy to be living in
Lancaster. Uh but in the Chicagoland
area, there's a lot of bureaucracy in
fighting tickets and uh Google shirts
can show that there have even been
instances with these red light camera
companies. I'm not sure if it'll be the
same one servicing the city, but in
getting completely wrong license plates
uh of people who they said, "Oh, this is
your car." And it actually wasn't their
car. It was someone else's car. And
there was no way to uh to fight it.
People had a hard time doing that. So I
would just if this was going to go into
place, I would make sure that there
would be a robust system for people to
fight the tickets uh so that they didn't
get wrongfully ticketed because you know
they are pricey. Um and then I would
echo the previous commenters uh the
speaker's thoughts about other ideas for
safer streets like you know you can
narrow the streets. I I'm just saying
there's other ideas too that we don't
necessarily need to resort to just red
light cameras to slow down people. So,
please do not pass this.
>> Good evening. My name is John Allison,
400 block of West Lemon Street. Um, my
largest concern is going to be the
administrative burden that is placed
upon the residents of Lancaster. Just
seeing if there is a false signal or
something like that, how the appeals
process is going to go. It's an
automated system, so it's basically
placing the majority of that
administrative burden on Lancaster uh
residents. As well as I was looking at
the proposal, I saw it cost about a
$100,000 per traffic light. And I'm just
wondering if this is the best use of
funds compared to having other public
safety measures throughout Lancaster.
Um, one of the things I've seen a lot of
times while I'm driving around the city
is um not is the motorized bicycles or
the uh different types of scooters that
people uh ride around very fast. And
I've there's been numerous accidents
here in the city where people have been
where they run red lights. None of those
vehicles are required to have license
plates or have any ability to be fined
because they're more like a bicycle than
they are a commuting traffic like a
commuter car or a motorcycle
when I see that they are as much of a
danger or in as much a danger as a
motorcycle going with within the speed
limits on city property or like within
the city limits. So, those are my two
things that I think is just if we're
looking at this potential uh
administrative burden. And then I'm just
wondering if that's going to actually
stop um people going through the red
lights. I know in the early mornings a
lot of people go through um especially
down like Prince Street and they'll use
the uh progressive green lights to start
almost preemptively going through the
red lights. I know that can cause
accidents. So, I just wanted to know
what that is. And then also the uh time
difference between someone, let's say
they enter a yellow light, when does
that um red light camera start taking
effect? Like are they if they're halfway
through the intersection when it turns
red? Because if some of these uh traffic
signals are very very fast. So I just
wanted to know what when people are
going to be get penalized and if so, do
we know any more additional information
on that? Thank you.
>> Thank you. Is that something that
you could answer?
>> Yeah, I mean related to um
when they would be fine. I mean they
have to they would enter have to enter
the intersection. So if you're at an
intersection waiting to make a left turn
lane and you're in the intersection and
it turns red while you're in that would
not count. It has to be you're once you
you're entering the intersection after
the light has turned red. So if you're
in the intersection during any part of
the yellow phase, you would not be
>> gotcha.
>> have a violation.
>> Thank you. And one other question I'd
ask is could we also possibly spend
better money by using uh installing more
opticoms on the street lights for
emergency response vehicles. Um, I know
that a lot of the uh streets of the
city, especially around the hospital,
where there are a lot of emergency
response vehicles, they don't have the
ability to have optic or uh areas where
those could be actually very well
implemented compared to installing these
red light street cameras. So, instead of
having emergency vehicles cutting across
traffic on a green light, instead of
making it a
>> red light. Thank you.
Tony Dastro, 700 block of New Holland
Avenue. Uh, whenever I see this sort of
legislation, I do get a little bit
weirded out cuz like, you know, Uber
driver. So, I've seen plenty of other
Uber drivers and I know how it is when
uh enforcement picks up, but I do think
it's a good thing. I do think that these
sort of enforcements are necessary for
our community. I I kind of joke about
the whole Uber driver deal, but uh no, I
I've driven Philly for a summer and the
red light cameras work there. The speed
cameras work there. Um and I certainly
was watching my behavior in streets I
wasn't familiar with when I saw photo
enforcement. Um but I want to encourage
you on one change. Uh I believe it said
that there's like, you know, civil
penalties for these. Uh, I would
encourage city council to amend it to
include that the court may at their
discretion designate these penalties can
be paid by community service. Um,
there's other ordinances that allow for
that, not traffic, but I do think this
is applicable here because it's a civil
offense. Uh, and I think it makes sense
because the city every year we do bike
counts and if people are running red
lights and they do end up happening
getting a fence, it could provide an
opportunity for the city to source
volunteer labor to help with these
traffic counts in the future. Um, so and
also if somebody can't really afford the
$100, but they learned their lesson, you
know, it provides an opportunity there
as well. So there's a real benefit to
amending this to include uh diverse ways
of pay. I've always called it fines of
time. Uh, and that's what I would
encourage the council on. Thank you.
>> Wasn't expecting to come up here, but
um, Nathan Charles um hopefully 4 400
block of West Lemon. Um,
so I I had a question. So, who who is
responsible for the the enforcement of
these cameras?
>> Enforcement. I mean the police are the
ones that would actually issue the
tickets.
>> Yeah. But in terms of uh the operation,
so there was there was an observation
that potentially we could add additional
function um for enforcement like uh
turning a right on a red
>> that's still running a red light I
guess. So that's that's
what would be covered. So the question
is could could could the um the what
these uh cameras ticket be changed uh in
the future
>> only with legislative changes for at the
state level.
>> Okay. Now the this in Chicago they
changed the timing of the of yellow
lights. They shortened the yellow lights
to increase um the by a tenth of a
second. Is is there any chance that that
would happen here?
>> No. We
>> I would say there's something in the
ordinance I was just reading that says
that we can't deviate from the standard
set by the by PENDOT.
>> Okay. Um
appreciate it because I've I've been hit
twice in a crosswalk walking on green.
So definitely uh in very um uh want to
see more safety in crosswalks, but at
the same time um you know I've heard
some good good comments here. don't want
to make sure that we're we're
exacerbating any problems. Um so anyway,
thanks.
>> Great.
>> Quickly, I just uh Susie Hoover um I was
out of state for an event with a family
and my hostess who was older had me
drive and as I drove through the city
and I did not know this, she said,
"Drive faster." And I said, "No, but the
speed limit says this." She said, "Don't
worry." When I got home, I did have two
photographs of my car speeding with this
type of system. I didn't go through a
red light. It was actually on the
street. And I went, there was my license
plate, there was the camera. Clearly, it
was me. So, I actually got points out of
it. I almost thought about writing my uh
writing my hostess, but she was such a
cool lady. I thought I wouldn't and I
just paid it. But this system does work.
It does work.
>> Thank you.
>> And just to reiterate, this is not speed
enforcement. That that is procluded by
state law. We are not allowed to use
cameras for speed enforcement. There is
only one place that cameras are allowed
for speed enforcement, and that is
Philadelphia.
>> Yep.
If there's no other comments, I would
like to go ahead and move this to full
counsel on October 14th.
>> Second.
>> All in favor?
>> I.
>> Thank you very much. And the next one is
uh council bill um052025
creating a community police review
board. Um, I think this has been hanging
for what, three or four months now.
Nobody's responding. Um, the bill was
sent. I've met with the mayor and
several police officers that were in the
panel and the response was that it was
illegal. And just to make it clear, it's
not illegal because Pittsburgh has a
beautiful um website that has a citizens
police review board. So, anybody that
wants to take a look at that, you're
welcome to see it. They have the
meetings there. Um, and I'm just going
to basically say it, you know, I'm going
to bring it forward because as I told
them, I'm here to support the community.
This is what the community wanted and
this is my job.
Whether they vote for it, I doubt it
very highly. But at least you know that
I did my job.
Okay. So, if there's any questions from
council, go ahead. Um I'm
You can You've already had the bill for
what, a month and a half now? Um and if
not, I'll open up to the public if they
want to make comments on it.
>> Councelor Diaz, if I may. Go ahead.
>> Um, from the public safety committee,
uh, my questions were, um, was there any
legal review of this resolution when it
was written?
>> Well, if you heard the mayor and she
told me that it was illegal, it was very
interesting that if if a different
state, I mean, a different um, county
has it, it's obviously not illegal. And
if you look at it and you read it,
there's nothing there that's going to
show that they're going to be any voting
power whatsoever. It's just to have a
community people and it's going to
include police officers. Even though I
know for sure that some people in the
community feel that that's not really
the reason to have it. It's more for the
for you to say, "Look, this person broke
the law. This person was aggressive.
This person, you know, did not follow
the law." Um but this is very simple. I
mean even city council is going to be
appointing um the even police officers
is going to be on there social worker
and community members. It's not any type
of pro voting power whatsoever.
>> Thank you. And and my question was when
it was written was there any legal
review? Not when you met with the
administration but when the resolution
was written was there any legal review?
I would have to go back and look at my
emails cuz this has been a while.
>> And that goes to my second point, you
know, um, with the current collective
bargaining agreement, was there any
thought into how some type of apparatus
such as a public safety commission
review board um, whatever it may be, how
that works with our current community,
uh, with our current, uh, agreement with
the with
>> I can send you that information. I don't
I just don't have it, unfortunately. I
have a fever, so I'm a little bit out of
it today, but um I will I can forward
that to everyone in city council. And if
you have a question, Tony, go ahead.
>> Well, last I'm not I'm not finished.
>> Oh, you're not finished. Go ahead. Uh
and and and lastly, I would just, you
know, like to note that, you know,
without any robust input from the
solicitor's office, from the chief of
police, and given that we're going to
have a new chief of police, a new
administration, and a new public safety
commission, um I I don't think this
resolution is appropriate. And that's my
final comment.
I would also like to I guess ask the
question if like if the administration's
position is that it's not legal. I would
want to know what the what the reasoning
or like
um
you know I I
if if that was if that was said then I I
would want to know you know what the
what the reasoning behind that is. Was
there any discussion about
um like like whether this constitutes
mandated participation without
compensation on the behalf of the
officers because that would violate the
collective bargaining agreement. Um you
know, I think there's a lot of folks
that have really
uh pushed for this that told me when
they saw this that it wasn't to their
liking. And I think it goes back to the
original point that Mayor Sarra made in
March, which is that I think the
unfortunate reality is that this would
create a misalignment of expectations.
Did you discuss what review or what
evidence would be admissible to such a
board?
>> Like I said before, I'd have to forward
that information to you because I have
it all written down and I would be happy
to.
>> Okay. And I also will send you the
citizen police review board from
Pittsburgh.
>> I don't have any other questions. I
definitely do not feel comfortable with
this given all of those concerns and not
getting
an answer.
>> Councelor Diaz, may may I ask a
question?
>> I'm just right ahead.
>> Yeah. I'm just curious. I feel like we
jumped right into this, but typically
with ordinances, I know we do a review
of the process and also the highlights
of the ordinance. Would you mind
presenting the ordinance and talking to
us a little bit about your process in
drafting this ordinance? Did you draft
it? Did the solicitor draft it? kind of
curious about
>> I'm gonna gohead and I worked pardon me
I worked with Tony in regards to this
and I also was working with um some of
the Pittsburgh people that I know up
there
>> who who are the Pittsburgh people
>> city council I'll forward that
information as well
>> looking forward to it thank you
>> so I put most of this together
>> council Diaz may I address before we
take public comment thank you um I I had
ample opportunity to review this because
I think this has come up for 3 months
now and I have some lingering questions.
Um
um most notedly about the participation
of the police social worker that's
proposed here. Um as an employee of the
police department, I would be very
concerned about having another employee
have access to personnel records. Um
that seems to me a pretty distinct
violation. Um I I think that it that
just speaks to the nature of this um
particular bill being written without
any sort of regard or legal review. It
seems like from an employment law
perspective um that that seems pretty
basic. Is there did anyone look at this
from an employment law perspective when
it was drafted?
>> That I did not go through but I can.
>> Thank you.
The mic is open.
>> Okay. Tony Dasher, 700 block of New
Holland Avenue. Yes. So, most of what
you're seeing before you uh was put
together by myself, sent to them, Miss
Diaz for her review. Uh, and no, I did
not have a lawyer look over it prior.
Um, this is one of those rare examples
where a community member puts together
an ordinance and then gives it to
council and action can or cannot be
taken. Um, frankly, the most upsetting
thing for me over these last three
months is to see the lack of action
here. I said these words would circle
back. Good faith. Faith without works is
dead. And we as the public have not
observed the work taking place to get
these sort of initiatives done. Yes, we
have the citizens police academy which
I've uh signed myself up to participate
in. I think that has a place in these
sort of discussions, but it's not a
replacement for these sort of
mechanisms. Yes, this is not
disciplinary, but while I did not get
legal review, I did read the union
contract. The point that I think is most
valid to make here, Mr. Hirs said, uh,
compensation if you're going to be on
this board and you're a member of the
police force. The reason there are
frankly more positions than just the
chief listed there uh because I would
suspect that the chief would be
compensated as it would become a
necessary part of their function to
participate.
I think that's a valid question to ask
and frankly I would be comfortable not
having those other police members on but
I included them in my draft because I
thought it gave a a diversity of
perspectives not just the executive
function of the police department. So
that's why those other police members
are there. And if we wanted to replace
him with community members, that's fine.
But the reason why I think it's
necessary for y'all to move this
forward, not to approve it as is, to
continue having these discussions in
public where we can call the police to
present their position, where we can get
legal review on these matters so we can
answer these questions because we need
some change on this issue.
We need some change on this issue and we
need to move this forward to continue
the conversations because otherwise I
personally will acknowledge for the rest
of my life that this moment occurred and
there was no desire to continue the
conversation because regardless of a new
mayor, regardless of a new police chief,
y'all are the city council and you are
responsible for drafting the legislation
for which the mayor has to enforce and
the police have to follow. this is the
place and time to have these
conversations,
especially when we're about to undergo
change. So, that's what I have to say. I
think your questions, Miss Diaz, are
valid. Um, but the public deserves those
answers as well. We need to continue
this as an open process. That's how we
build transparency and trust in our
police. Thank you.
Jessica Lopez, Lancaster city resident,
and thank God we're finally at this
point. Um, I want to say that it's kind
of disappointing where I can't stand all
the way with this resolution. I feel
like it's very disappointing that you
aren't taking this serious, that you
aren't doing the background search since
March 2nd to find a way to quell the
distrust between city council, our
police department, and our city
residents. The fact that Tony had to
create some type of proposal and then
get the one most pro police city council
member we have to put this forward says
a lot. Um I think that being I can't
stand with it being that our city
solicitor just signed on with our
district attorney to try to silence the
transparency in the March 2nd video
incident that we're still fighting for.
We can't trust that our city is here to
protect us. They are literally
meeting November 4th on election day to
decide whether these body cam footages
are allowed or not. Who's going to be in
that courtroom that's sitting up here
that vowed to protect us?
I would hope that, you know, the
protection of our children would be more
important than elections and stuff. And
when that court proceeding goes on
November 4th, somebody from city council
will be there because these are very
important decisions that are being made.
No, this police working group as it
stands right now, I cannot stand with, I
can't agree with. We do need an
authoritative stance from our community
to our police department. We do need a
voice at the table when that collective
bargaining agreement is being revisited
coming up. We do need a say in our own
protection because every response that
came from you guys to this proposal is
if the police were going to be protected
in this and not if the community was
actually going to be protected. We asked
if a social worker being involved is
going to release police information.
What about the protection of our
residents? That's what we're asking for.
It might not look like this police
working group that was proposed to you,
but it does look like the the ass for
the last 8 months
since that bike incident transpired
outside. All we're asking for is for you
to really do what you said Jews would do
when you ran to get up here.
Like, that's sad. A man, there's times
I've come up and spoken for you. There's
times I've come up and spoken on behalf
of a lot of things that people are
proposing up here. And yet again, every
day you sit in these seats and do not
speak for us, but we're worried about
the protection of our police officers.
Yes, there is a working group in
Pittsburgh that oversees their police
department. There's also a court watch
set up in Pittsburgh. Pittsburgh does a
lot to protect their residents, not just
capitalize them. Lancaster literally sat
here for hours, pushed this to the very
end, and then acted like our ass are
wrong. No, we need protection, and we
put y'all in place to do it. So, if we
need lawyers to review and figure out
how we can legally get a resident review
board of our police department, that's
your job. That's not Tony's job. That's
not this community's job. That's your
guys's job to figure out how to protect
the people that put you in place.
So yes, we do need a police working
group. It's not the one that is put in
this proposal that this does need tabled
though. It does need revisited and you
need to do your job to make it so that
this resolution fits our community.
That's it. Thank you.
Well, it looks like um we can go ahead
and table it while I forward all the
information to you. And I'll also um
send you the draft that um Pittsburgh
has um that can be looked at as well and
I'll send it to the solicitor. Go ahead.
Um, hi. My name is Taylor, Taylor
Interline, uh, community organizer with
Lancaster stands up, part of Mannheim
Burrow. Um, I do appreciate Tony taking
the time to bring this and funnel it
through. Janet, I do think though I
don't see how it's different from what
came out of 2020 and that has dissolved.
Um, and our community has asked for more
something with teeth. And so I would ask
that like regardless if you know the
convers the conversation cannot stop
here regardless of what you vote on this
but that each of you would take the time
to work with folks whether that's
community organizers community folks if
it is the police to figure out what the
solution here is because something does
need to give. I mean we are going to get
a new chief we are going to get a new
mayor and I hope that those folks are
willing to like work with the community.
We are told all the time to come to the
table and continuously we do and so I
hope that something is on the table for
us to actually have some power here when
we talk about our police and how our
folks are policed here in the city.
Thank you.
>> I'll make a motion to table bill number
five.
>> Could you specify until when? And I'm
I'm want to be clear about this because
I do think that there is uh some
community conversation that council
should have uh and some other
conversation and I would look to
councelor Diaz to lead that. I think
Taylor's point, Miss Underline's point
is well taken.
you're asking for something with teeth
and I am suggesting that there are many
legal barriers to that at the state and
some at the local level that are not
even addressed by what Pittsburgh has.
And so I find myself in this
conversation again and again since 2017
in trying to respond to the requests
from the community to respond with
something with accountability, with
something with teeth.
Show me another community in
Pennsylvania that has a citizen police
review board with teeth.
Show me. I think um to answer that
question um there's another one that
Harrisburg has which I still have to um
look at that again. I don't I I believe
that the mayor hasn't appointed her
staff according to the conversation I
have with one of the city council
members, but um yeah, we just have to
continue speaking to the community and
we have to look at what we can draw up.
But I mean, we continue. I mean, the
only thing that's going to happen is
another incident's going to occur where
something's going to be even worse
and they're going to come back here
again. They're going to tell you, "I
want something now." And
how many months later or how many years
later?
>> You know, councelor Diaz, maybe it's
because I'm nearing the end of my term,
but I just want to say that when you
came to the meeting, the police chief
was at the head of the table. You were
sitting to his left. I was sitting
across from you. We were joined by six
or eight police officers. And your point
of view was that
you repeated what you said earlier
tonight that you were at this meeting to
represent
um the community. You did not make a
case for the ordinance. You simply
stated that this was you were there
because the community wanted you there
and you don't have any problems with the
police. So I take great great umbrage at
the way that you are presenting yourself
tonight as some champion of the
community on this issue. Thank you.
>> I would like to close then. I mean I
there was a table there.
>> We had a motion to table. I did not hear
a second. Um, this is your committee,
but it is parliamentarian advice.
>> I would
I mean, if we're making a motion to to
table, um, you know, I I I I I
will state again that I do not support
this for the reasons that were
affermentioned, that it creates a
misalignment between the community's
expectations
and reality, and that that's kind of the
issue at hand. And that's that's that's
kind of emblematic to me of the
conversations I've been having of people
who saw this and said, "Well, I don't
like that there's three police officers
on it, and I don't like that it doesn't
have teeth." And there is no such, you
know, as the mayor stated, there's not
there's no example of that in
Pennsylvania. So, I I I don't support
it. And I'm I like I'm tableabling it as
in like I'm done with the conversation.
Um, and if that means we have to table
it until January 2026, that's my motion.
>> A second.
>> So to be clear, because my question with
the tableabling is, you know, when are
we tableabling this till, you know, what
steps are going to be taken by the chair
of this committee uh in that time? Um,
and I I I don't want us to continue to
keep coming to this conversation about
these same root flawed issues within
this proposal. If we want to give the
new administration and the new um uh
police chief time to work this out and
report back in January, I I think that's
something that the public safety
committee at that time could request.
Um, but tableabling this till next year,
I I I I don't feel is appropriate.
And that does not mean that we can't
continue to have community conversations
with, you know, folks, with community
groups. Um, but but simply tableabling
the same flawed document is is not going
to result in any change that the public
is looking for, nor would be productive
for this body.
>> Well, if if anything, I can table it
till the 28th so I can get all the
information out and get more people on
the on at the table.
Unless there's a problem, which is fine.
>> I'm here for the people.
>> The 28th would be our second meeting in
October. And I don't Mr. Harris, I
believe we would need this to come
through committee as a bill. Yes. So it
the ve the earliest would be our
committee meeting in November, which
would be November 3rd if if that's the
intent. Um
yes, ma'am.
Hey. Um, I just I wanted to respond um
to everyone in the mayor specifically is
I don't think I I think you're right.
Like we can look at other places in PA
and try and see what we can resemble. I
don't think what what I'm saying is I
don't think we should recreate what came
out of 2020 and died and nothing came
out of it. What I think is like we
should there should be a conversation of
what we can like move forward. I know
we're not going to get every little
thing in terms of what it is with teeth.
I know in terms of the state level, in
terms of here locally, in terms of like
dealing with the DA's office, but I do
think there are ways that we could work
together to get something that is more
substantial than what was proposed and
that there's a conversation that can
continue to be had outside of what is
proposed as well. I I don't know the
exact date um in terms of when the next
bargaining uh like contract goes in or
um what those conversations need to be
had even before you know a new
administration comes in or before a new
chief comes in like I think groundwork
can continue to be laid outside of what
is proposed and I would hope that we
don't table till indefinitely that
there's conversations that are still
happening outside of what is in front of
you that's what I would ask
>> thank you And I would just say that as I
come to the conclusion of my term and
there is an effort that's currently um
getting started to hire a new police
chief that it would really be premature
to I think it would be in the
community's best interest to engage the
new mayor and the police chief in these
conversations in order to be able to
have the kind of robust conversation
that's necessary. And I think that that
is part of an expectation of hiring a
new chief is engaging in the community
to talk about ways to continue to build
trust and rapport. I would like for that
chief to have that opportunity. And so
my recommendation is like just set this
down. I don't really trust where this is
all going. Just me personally as a city
resident, set it down. have the
opportunity to engage in these
conversations. Be clear about um
expectations around community
engagement, involvement. If you're not
happy about the way that the community
working group fell apart, there just
wasn't any participation. And so there
and and that is a challenge. And so it
it did it fell it did fall apart. and
some other really good things were born
out of that that that we're working on
now with the school district and PCCD
around youth gun violence and things
like that. So, it's not like nothing
happened. Um, and you know, I also just
want to take note, you know, I was
I did not have a great relationship with
the police department and did not have a
lot of confidence in them early in my
tenure. And that has changed for me and
I think it can continue to change for
this community as well. We have come so
far since 2020 in the work that this
community has done together with our
police bureau and I am really proud of
that work and I want to see it continue
and I think that these kinds of
conversations get muddled in the
expectations being set beyond what can
actually be delivered. So, you know, I
just I think also to to council, you
have a budget to pass, you have a home
rule, administrative code to pass,
you've got a zoning text amendment, and
whatever else we are going to throw at
you between now and the end of the year
and there are 10 meetings left. So, I
just want to be realistic in a holiday
season through all of the work that's
ahead. Is this really going to become
the priority before the end of this and
before we can name a new police chief?
Just being real.
>> I would just quickly respond in terms of
I 100% hear what you're saying and not
saying that anything didn't come out of
it. I hear what you're saying in terms
of what is happening between the end of
the year. I just don't think the
conversation should die and I think that
there could be conversations and steps
taken before the new chief comes in to
engage with him and or him or them or
her in that way. And that's all I will
have to say. Thank you.
>> Citizen uh Tony Dasher 700 block Avenue
Citizens Police Oversight Commission out
in Philadelphia appears to have some
teeth to it. Um, the commission works to
increase transparency and
>> they're a class one city, Mr. Dastra.
They operate under different rules.
>> Yeah. And we also needed to get police
accreditation to get red light cameras.
There are certain mechanisms. So, I
guess what I'm really trying to make the
point of is that you asked for another
municipality. I gave you one. What we as
the public need is education on this
perspective. This goes all the way back
to other issues. We should have like if
we're going to work on this, you wanted
reports from the police, right? On this
issue, let's let's lay it out on paper
like here's why.
>> I have been talking about this since
2017. Name me a class 3 city that has
any teeth. Show me.
>> Now you're changing the question. The
point is that I answered the exam
question, but what I'm asking in
response is for written stuff the public
can read on their own time so we can get
educated as well as y'all who are going
to be here next year. So actually what I
would recommend instead of January, and
I'm asking this of you specifically,
councelor Med, I'd love it if that in
February of next year after you return
to council, you request this
conversation be brought to the public
safety subcommittee with some of this
documentation. Not cuz yeah this thing
was so flawed. Clearly it was flawed
from the beginning when I put it
together because I was of the
perspective based off someone up here on
the deis that advisory would be fine but
then it got met with a bunch of hurdles.
What we as the public need to help you
move forward is information. So I guess
I'm asking you are you willing to get
some of this information prepared over
the next 5 months for us? not all at
once, but just are you willing to work
towards this and revisit this issue
again in February once all the budget
stuff is died down and everything new is
in place.
>> I mean, I I'll answer your question, Mr.
Dashra, and uh as been stated by other
members of council and other members of
the community, we are all engaged in
continuing conversations and uh and
increasing relationships between the
community and the police. Now, what that
looks like with the new council, with
the new administration, with the new uh
chair of the public safety committee and
the new council, uh I think that we
should give those opportunities to
actualize first. Uh and then we could
continue to have those conversations as
we are continuing to go on. Uh but as
you stated, you wrote this, it was
flawed. As elected official, I do not
feel it's appropriate to move forward
with it at this time. But no one ever
said that that is going to cease
conversations which we always strive to
have uh with community members.
>> Sure. So what I didn't ask you was to
move this forward in February. What I
asked you is are you willing to get some
written material put together for the
public to understand what we have to do
to put teeth in this as a thirdass city.
>> Mr. Dasher, as we've stated before, we
are all in we're all engaged and
committed to continue to do the work
that we're elected to do. And that is
going to be my final questions, my final
remarks on that.
>> Feel like it's the Senate right now.
>> Council Diaz, this is still your
committee. Um I have lost track of
whether we have a motion at this point.
So just a reminder,
>> I think it did, didn't it? Um I wasn't
sure if Amed
>> I didn't hear
>> I will make a clear motion to table
this.
>> Thank you sir. Until when?
>> Indefinitely. I it the the conversation
we we cannot have a conversation about
this until a police chief has been named
at the minimum. Like it this is this is
getting ridiculous.
>> Table it and we'll have the conversation
at a more appropriate time.
>> Mr. Harris, do we have to have we need a
specific date for tableabling? Is that
correct? We do not know.
>> We do not. Great. Thank you.
Okay.
Is somebody going to I'll move forward
then? Definitely.
Is there anyone else? Is Amed going to
agree to that?
>> Well, if there was a motion and a
second, it would go to a vote of the
committee.
>> All in favor?
>> Was there a second?
He was He seconded. You I make
>> There is a motion in a second. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> I did not
>> I did not second. I thought you
seconded, Councelor Diaz. So, I was
waiting for the vote to come.
>> If there's a a motion without a second,
the motion fails.
>> I second it.
>> I made the motion. He second it. Hersh.
>> Mr. Harris, can you help as the
parliamentarian?
>> Um, Madame President, my understanding
is that Mr. Hirs made the motion. Uh,
the question is still uh before you for
a second. If councelor Diaz is seconding
the amendment, then there can be a vote
for it.
>> Is there a second to councelor Hirs's
motion?
>> I second it.
>> I think you'll call the vote now. This
is this is your committee. So you may
call a vote.
>> All in favor?
>> I
>> I.
>> And that concludes the safety committee.
>> Thank you. We'll move to the committee
of the whole and I will endeavor to be
brief because of the late hour this
evening. We do have two items on our
committee of the whole agenda versus
bill number nine 2025. This is a bill
reallocating American Rescue Plan Act
funds that were granted to the Lancaster
Recreation Commission uh for a different
use than what it was intended. Um I
don't know if we have anyone that's
speaking to it. Director Campbell, I
appreciate that. I' be happy to take a
stab at it, but I welcome you up.
>> Thank you.
>> So, thank you very much. This is an
opportunity for us to make sure that
ARPA funds that were designated for one
purpose can be continue to be used for a
very similar in inline purpose. Um so
the change in use for the ARPA plan for
the ARPA funds was granted to the
Lancaster Recreation Commission for
renovation of the Price Elementary
School.
We're wanting since since Lancaster
wreck has determined that they're not
going to go forward with with price, we
want to be able to spend the remainder
of the ARPA dollars on other aspects of
the renovation of the Lan existing
Lancaster Direct facility which include
HVAC,
refurbishment of the elevator and
refurbishment of the of the the
structural bridge that the entrance
bridge if there are sufficient funds.
The funds that had been allocated to
from ARPA were $750,000.
Uh we believe that there's about $37,000
left. However, both uh Lancaster Rec and
SDOL are confirming what has and has now
been spent on the price building for not
only asbestous abatement but for
structural purposes.
Um, we have reasonable estimates that
the HVAC, which which DPW and the city
of Lancaster have been hobbling along
with for the past two or three years
with just window units can be performed
for for under $300,000.
So, if there is remaining $37,000
and in then we can get the HVAC done to
everyone's satisfaction. If we get
better bids, then we can go into the
into the elevator, which is a we're
which we're estimating to be about 95 to
$150,000 to do the elevator. Um and
that's because the elevator has is
several years beyond its remaining
useful life and it as a facility that
uses that uh is used by these seniors as
well as a wide variety of of individuals
having uh handicapped accessibility
throughout the facility would be very
very important.
If we can only use the 307,000, if
there's only 307,000 left, that's
wonderful for as far as we're concerned.
And we will continue through the
facility condition assessment process to
identify capital projects that can
support the Lancaster Rec facility
itself. So the the goal here is to be
able to legally allow I mean the the the
money
section 804 of the third class city code
says that money may not be paid out of
the city treasury except by an
appropriation made in accordance with
the law and council may by ordinance
make supplemental appropriation for any
lawful purpose from any money in the
city treasury. So, what we're asking is
for the council to make that lawful
supplemental appropriation.
>> Thank you very much, Director Campbell.
Um, being well acquainted with the needs
of that building, I appreciate that we
were going to be able to to move those
funds into this purpose. Um, since the
original one is is not able to move
forward. Um, question for you. Um, just
a procedural question. And are we uh are
you asking for us to be move this to our
meeting on the 14th to expedite this
process?
>> Yes, we are.
>> Great.
>> Um and part of that is part of that is
not just because of being expeditious,
but ARPA funds need to be spent by the
end of 2026.
>> Y
>> and we have the means to be able to
spend these dollars within that time
frame very very comfortably without
delay. And as it is, the HVAC is
something that could benefit the use of
the facility not only in the not only in
the summertime for cooling, but in the
winter time for heating.
>> Yes. And desperately needed in both
cases.
>> Thank you. Any comments from council on
the bill
from the public?
Hear none. I'll make a motion to move
this to our meeting on October 14th.
>> Second.
>> All in favor? I
>> I. Any opposed?
Thank you, Dr. Campbell. Uh, last item
on our agenda this evening is our
resolution number 64, 2025, recognizing
employee ownership month. This is
originated from councelor Royo.
>> Thank you, council president. Um,
October is employee ownership month. So,
this resolution celebrates businesses
where employees aren't just team
members, but they're actually owners of
the business. Employee owned businesses
thrive on shared success where every
voice matters and also their
contributions counts for everyone. Um
you may recognize a nationally known
employee owned business that's right
here in our city which is Cargus. Uh the
founder uh founder and former CEO Chip
Cargus started Tandem Center for Shared
Business Success which is a nonprofit
based here in Lancaster uh that helps
guide companies not just in Lancaster
but across the nation become
employeeowned. Um and it's just one
example on how Lancaster is being a
leader in the business for good
movement. Um this resolution recognized
this is this recognizes October as um
employee ownership month and celebrates
that success.
Thank you very much. Council Royal. Any
council comments on the resolution?
Oh, and I apologize. I didn't make a
motion before I did that. Um I would
make a motion to move resolution number
to council on the 14th.
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Any com council comments on
the resolution? Just procedural uh
comments from the public on the
resolution.
Okay. Hearing none. All in favor?
>> I.
>> Any opposed? No. All right. Very good.
Um we have received the clerk's report
in writing before this meeting. Uh Mr.
Harris, thank you very much for that.
Um, and having reached the conclusion of
our agenda, I'll hear a motion to
adjurnn.
>> Motion.
>> Motion to adjourn.
>> Oh, don't all jump at once. A second.
>> Second.
>> Hear a second. All in favor?
>> I.
>> We're journ. Thank you.
>> Time.